What's up friends? As always, welcome,
welcome, welcome wherever and whenever
you may be watching. Hope you're doing
well. Tonight we're going to be
continuing
our examination and response to Pastor
John Lomachang and a talk that he gave
on the Adventist satellite TV station
3ABN which was titled Protestantism has
been hijacked.
And if you saw part one, we saw how Mr.
Lomang, who is not alone in this by the
way, upheld the idea that the SDA church
is the last remaining bastion of true
Protestantism
because of their disdain for Roman
Catholicism.
But as we saw, disdain for Romanism is
not what makes you Protestant, at least
not historically.
We looked at a number of the hallmarks
of first generation Protestantism and
showed how the SDA church meets
virtually none of those hallmarks. So to
claim that they are heirs of the
Protestant Reformation is not only false
but almost comical. So if you didn't see
that part, I highly recommend checking
that out as we went over quite a bit and
we did some foundation laying for this
presentation. The link to that is in the
description box down below. Now,
tonight, like I said,
we're going to be responding to Mr.
Lomang, but he's going to get into a
variety of things as he is going to
transition into some of their chief
claims such as the seventh day Sabbath
being the final test in the end,
functioning as the dividing line between
those who truly worship and follow God
and those who don't. We're going to get
into the history of hell,
a very similar story to what he heard uh
or what we heard rather from Doug
Bachelor a few weeks ago. Uh and a
number of other things. But if you
recall from part one, I pointed out a
number of times that the enemy in the
sights, folks, Christian, listen,
the enemy in the sights of the SDA
church is professing Christians.
You have to get this Christian. You have
to get this.
It's those of us that go to church on
Sunday. Not Islam, not communism, not
secularism, not atheism, Christians.
Their crusades, their messages. It's all
built around doom and gloom of the
Sunday keepers who are backsliden into
apostasy. and they're here to enlighten
us and save us from damnable error.
We're their enemy.
Remember that. It's so important to
remember that when you hear talks like
this
because this movement loves to put up
the front that they're just another
Protestant denomination to try and buddy
buddy up with Christians in hopes to
make inroads to begin proitizing
Christians with the sort of stuff that
you're going to hear tonight. often
times
they don't want to come right out and
just say what they really feel about
Christians because they know it's going
to close up doors for them to try and
evangelize us.
This is actually one thing I respect
about Mr. Lomang. He's a different
generation of Adventist and he isn't
afraid to show his hand and lay his
cards on the table letting the chips
fall where they may. But
because we like evidence around here
to evidence and back up my claim
regarding these sneaky tactics often
utilized by Adventists, let's do some
foundation laying like we typically do.
I will start by saying no, not all SDAs
are aware of these quotes. No, not all
SDAs are nefarious people. No, not all
SDAs are deceptive. That isn't what I am
saying. But the SDA church, regardless
of what they, you know, people want to
claim, they march to the orders of their
inspired prophetist who they believe is
the infallible interpreter of scripture
like we have looked at multiple times,
including in part one. And it is her
instructions to their movement that are
seen as a beacon of light amidst chaos.
And you better believe that the SDA
leadership heeds her counsel across the
board. So, in the last part, we looked
at how the SDA church defines Babylon
and the term apostate Protestantism.
Something else he's going to bring up
tonight again, which is Roman Catholics
and Protestantism that are supposedly
linking arms in hopes of taking over the
American government to mandate that
everyone observe Sunday as the Sabbath.
as this impending doom is on the
horizon. They believe God has raised
their movement up as a prophetic witness
to warn the world of this and to call
them the the whole world including
Christians
as the supposed remnant church who
worships in spirit and truth which only
is contained in the SDA church. Don't
let them fool you that oh there's lot
they love to when they're defending the
Sabbath to try and say oh there's lots
of sabotarian groups out there right and
you guys think they're in just as much
of danger because they don't have the
spirit of prophecy they don't have the
three angels messages yada yada
so part of their strategy is to form
relationships with Christians to begin
slowly evangelizing them with their
talking points and their teachings.
Notice the counsel that Ellen White
gives regarding pastors in other
churches and the instruction given to
SDAs, particularly SDA leadership.
This is when it comes to other pastors.
Get this quote.
We have a work to do for the ministers
of other churches.
God wants them to be saved.
They like ourselves can have immortality
only through faith and obedience.
We must labor for them earnestly that
they may obtain it.
God wants them to have a part in his
special work for this time. That's the
three angels messages.
He wants them to be among the number who
are giving to his household meat in due
season. Why should they not be engaged
in this work? Our ministers should seek
to come near to the ministers of other
denominations.
Pray for and with these men for whom
Christ is interceding. It's an
interesting uh we'll get into some of
that more later.
A solemn responsibility is theirs.
As Christ messengers, we should manifest
a deep earnest interest in these
shepherds of the flock. Close quote.
So God wants other ministers in other
churches to be saved. They aren't saved
because they don't have the three angels
messages like the SDA church does. When
she says they like ourselves can have
immortality only through faith and
obedience, she is referring to a twofold
work.
One is that these other ministers reject
the Adventist teaching on the nature of
man and the state of the dead, which
Ellen White claimed uh is one of the two
doctrines that will send people to
predition at lightning speed
as well as Sunday sacredness.
Immortality of the soul and Sunday
sacredness are the two doctrines that at
lightning speed will send somebody to
predition. So, because these ministers
affirm that God sustains the souls of
those who depart, we've looked at this
before.
They're lost and on the road to
predition. They also worship and preach
on Sunday, which like I said is the
other thing they supposedly need safe
from. That's the special work for this
time, the heralding of the third angel's
message, which is a call to forsake
worshiping on Sunday and come join them
or the wrath of God is going to be
poured out on you. Heeding this warning
is equated with obedience. And if you
reject the SDA message, you'll be lost.
Hence why God wants them to be saved,
but they aren't. So her advice is that
Adventist ministers should forge
relationships with these pastors as a
way of opening the door before them to
begin proitizing the three angels
messages to them so they can be saved.
Again, writing to an Adventist
missionary in Europe back in the early
advent, notice what she tells him.
Quote, "The great prejudice of the
Jewish nation of priests and rulers was
stirred up against Christ because the
people preferred to listen to Jesus
rather than to them. The very same
feelings of prejudice will be manifest
in the priests and rulers of this time.
We can do nothing that would close up
the way before us in this country like
taking a position of superiority and
putting before the people that we
consider them heathen.
In truth, they are worse than heathen.
But this we are not to tell them. The
clergy consider themselves as teachers,
highly religious, and their churches
send out missionaries to the work of
converting the savages. But to have the
implication that a similar work must be
done for them, the clergy, they would
consider the worst kind of insult. Close
quote.
So this missionary was sent to Europe to
spread the Adventist message. At the
time, there was virtually no SDA
presence there. So she wrote advice to
this gentleman or correspondents rather
on how to go about getting that started
and she uses one of her favorite
analogies which we've seen many times
before and that's to equate the
Christians of today with the religious
leaders of Jesus's day and their
movement is supposed to be Christ in the
analogy who is heralding the truth as
some humble servant and the religious
leaders meaning Christians are filled
with animosity toward them. is a
recurring thing with her. But just like
the religious leaders of Jesus's day,
the same feeling of prejudice will be
manifest in the religious leaders of our
day. Because of this, Adventists are to
do nothing that would close up the way
before them, including taking a position
of superiority by letting them know that
they are worse than heathen. The truth
is they are indeed worse than heathen,
but they're not to tell them this. And
why is that?
Because the clergy, that's the pastors,
consider themselves religious and they
send out their own missionaries to
evangelize the lost. So to outright tell
them they're no better than those that
they're sending missionaries to, they
would take great offense to that. Thus,
the door to start evangelizing them
would be closed off and they would be
insulted.
This is what this movement thinks of
Christians. No, not every individual
SDA. Yes, I'm fully aware that not all
SDAs are aware of these statements,
but that is irrelevant to the
organization and its official stances.
Despite the liberal wing of Adventism
trying to downplay Ellen White or
outright dismiss her, Ellen White's
council is not seen that way at the
organizational level. Do not let them
fool you.
That's what this organization believes
about you, Christian. You are worse than
the heathen.
This is what I mean by the the target in
the sights of this organization is
Christians. Which is why whenever they
try to cry foul about them getting
critiqued, I just laugh.
I don't feel any sympathy for you. I
feel no sympathy for you trying to act
like you're the victim when you are in a
movement who is definitionally an
accuser of the brethren.
Don't give me that. Not buying it. We
are supposedly enemy number one.
So, don't take the bait when they try to
tell you stuff like, "Hey, brother,
we're just like you, brother." No, they
aren't. No, you're not. You may think
that, and you may be a me a well-meaning
individual. Not saying you have any
animosity in your heart, etc., but no,
no, no, no. You you don't understand the
organization then that you're affiliated
with. There's a disconnect here.
And Christian, you need to explain to
them why firmly but lovingly. Explain
that. No, you align yourself with an
organization that is proitizing and
exalting a false Jesus, a false gospel,
and a false prophet.
An an organization that claims you are
worse than the heathen. All because you
don't accept their false gospel, of
which the seventh day Sabbath is only
one small part. We're lost. God is angry
with us. Our prayers are an abomination.
And God has raised them up to supposedly
bring us to the fullness of the truth
and save us from damnation.
all things that the council of their
prophetus has laid out that we've looked
at before.
So, this is what you're going to hear
tonight,
just not as plain and outright, which
I'll be breaking that down as we go
along. So, with that said, the thesis
for tonight, Adventists, listen, please.
The thesis for tonight,
it is not to address every possible
claim under the sun. In part one, Mr.
Lom King said multiple times that if it
isn't a plain thus sayeth the Lord then
it should be rejected. Remember that.
But the thesis for tonight
are John Lomang's claims a plain thus
sayaith the Lord.
Are John Lomckang's claims a plain thus
saith the Lord?
Because remember, he claimed that
Protestantism has been hijacked
and they're put put up this front that
they're the last bastion of true
Protestantism.
Yet Protestants never never agreed with
them on the seventh day Sabbath. First
generation Protestantism ever.
Yes, they will try and give the excuse
like we looked at that the light on the
Sabbath truth hadn't been given yet, but
now it has, so it's everyone's duty to
heed it. But I agree. Protestantism has
been hijacked by sects like the SDA
church who've tried to redefine what it
means to be Protestant and then reject
virtually all the hallmarks of
Protestantism. But keep this question at
the forefront of your minds as we
listen.
Is the seventh day Sabbath being the end
times final dividing line, a plain thus
sayeth the Lord?
That's what we're asking and examining
tonight. What I think you'll see is this
is another perfect example of how the
great controversy theme is the driving
factor in the SDA church, not scripture.
I'm going to say that again.
The great controversy theme is the
driving factor in the SDA church, not
scripture. That doesn't mean they don't
try to appeal to scripture like we're
going to see tonight and saw last week,
but it is after it's already been
distilled and filtered through the great
controversy theme. Scripture is merely
an accessory
that is funneled through the SDA
church's extra biblical worldview and
then that end product is branded as a
plain thus sayeth the Lord when it's
not. But to recall where we left off
last time, he was citing First Kings 18
with Ahab and Jezebel trying to make an
esqueological type typological parallel
to the to the end times. That
Protestants are Ahab jacking up with a
harlot, the Roman Catholic Church, and
the SDA church is like Elisha trying to
tell them the truth, but they just won't
listen. So, with that said, let's get
back into this.
This is what the Lord told Elijah to do.
First Kings chapter 18 and verse 19. And
the Bible says, "Now therefore, Elijah,
now therefore, send and gather
all Israel to me on Mount Carmel, the
450 prophets of Baal and the 400
prophets of Asher who eat at Jezebel's
table." Did you hear that, friends? God
is saying when you are believing false
doctrines, you are eating at Jezebel's
table. Well, who was Jezebel? She is the
Old Testament equivalent of the harlot
of Revelation chapter 17. Why is the
word harlot used? Because whenever you
cause a person to depart from the true
God, you are no longer a bride in a good
and upholding relationship. You are now
a bride who used to be married to the
true God, but now you are in apostasy.
And the Bible calls that the practice of
harlotry. God said to Elijah, "Get those
prophets together. Get Baal's prophets
and get Asher's prophets together." You
see, God commanded Elijah to gather the
anti-truth coalition on Mount Carmel.
And friends, let me tell you something.
God is commanding the same thing today.
We find before Jesus comes, there's
going to be another gathering of the
anti-truth coalition on the stage of the
last days. Revelation 16:16 verifies
this. Look at the Bible. The Bible says,
"And they gathered them together to the
place called in Hebrew Armageddon or
Argodon, however you'd like to
annunciate that word. What happened on
Carmel is going to happen again just
before Jesus comes on a world stage."
And apostate Protestantism is building a
bridge to Catholicism. And people that
prefer works rather than truth or
worship that makes me feel good rather
than truth that makes my character to to
be good are going to be a part of that
apostate stand on the stage of
Armageddon. The final anti-truth
coalition.
Anti-truth coalition and Protestants
linking with Romanism.
Jezebel's table equaling false believing
false doctrines. Mr. Lomachang,
the SDA church must be at the head of
the table then because you guys are
steeped in false doctrine.
Recall in part one, he claimed that to
believe any a single false doctrine
means that you're worshiping a false
god. any doctrine.
And we saw the sort of bulletproof
theology mindset that permeates much of
Adventism.
Mr. Lomachang, you guys have a false
gospel and a false god.
Just like Baal and Asher,
your guys' heavenly trio is a false god.
The Adventist Jesus isn't even real.
Jesus was not exalted to be made equal
with the father prior to the creation of
the earth such that he was given
authority that he didn't previously
possess and was then brought into the
councils of God that he previously
didn't have access to.
Jesus was not only a man that set his
divine nature aside when he incarnated
but then permanently gave up certain
divine attributes that he received in
his exaltation such as omnipresence.
Jesus is not wearing Levitical
priesthood garments working on dealing
with sin still in a second phase of the
atonement in heaven.
The real Jesus did not doubt his
resurrection and if his sacrifice would
be accepted while he was on the cross
because the devil was able to twist his
mind causing him to doubt. Doubt being
un unbelief and unbelief is a sin. The
real Jesus didn't cease to be conscious
for three days while his human body laid
in the grave with the father alone being
able to resurrect him.
He was conscious in his divinity the
same way uh the same exact way that he
was conscious prior to incarnating while
he was in the grave. His physical body
was dead. His human nature was dead. His
divinity was not. The real Jesus will
never stop mediating for his people
because he holds his priesthood forever
permanently.
And he lives forever to make
intercession for his people by virtue of
his indestructible, never- ending life.
The real Jesus is ruling and reigning as
a priest king simultaneously right now
by virtue of incarnating and adding unto
himself a human nature eternally
bridging the gap between God and man by
virtue of him being the God man himself.
He's not going to cease to be a priest
at a point in the future and then assume
the role of a king at that point. Now, I
could go on and on. All of these things
are claims that your prophet has claimed
about Jesus, demonstrating that Mr.
Lomang, you guys fit the bill of First
Kings 18 far better than Protestants.
And to and to prove it, we don't have to
make a bunch of baseless end times
typological claims to prove it.
First Kings 18 has nothing to do with
pointing to the end times where
Protestants are Ahab and have linked up
with the Roman Catholic Church who's
Jezebel and you guys are Elisha. This is
all being read into the text to try and
make your guys' great controversy
worldview seem biblical. You're taking a
foreign concept, preconceived belief,
and then bringing that to the scriptures
and reading it into the text because
none of what you just said, none of it
is a plain thus sayeth the Lord.
Elisha worshiped the true God. The
pagans worshiped false ones, actual
idols.
Not they had the true God, but simply
believed false things about him such
that they were worshiping a false god.
These people never had the true God.
Two chapters prior in First Kings 16,
we're told that King Ahab did more evil
in the eyes of the Lord than any of
those that came before him. He was in a
long line of of evil, wicked kings. And
we talked about this in passing in part
one.
They were off the rails from the
beginning by the time Ahab got power.
The point being, the figures in First
Kings 18 outright had a totally foreign
and fake god, which is precisely the
case with Adventism. The SDA church
simply calls their false god by the true
God's name. Unlike the pagans in first
first kings 18
he said God commanded Elijah to get
together the antir coalition on Mount
Carmel and God is plainly calling us
meaning Adventists to the same thing
today. Revelation 16 supposedly verifies
this. You garnered all that from
Revelation 16:16.
All of that's a plain thus sayeth the
Lord.
No. Again, you're reading your guys's
great controversy narrative into the
text, seeking to draw parallels that do
not exist. The text does not plainly say
this.
And the reason it drives me crazy when
they say this, folks, is because when
you push back on it, they'll often try
and say, "Well, you just don't believe
the Bible then. What total malarkey."
Just again, Mr. Lach King, the thing
you're saying God is calling people to
in this present day is the seventh day
Sabbath. You claimed in the last part
that we are apostate because we've
abandoned plain Bible truth and that to
be apostate means that you were once
sound. Yet Protestants never agreed with
you guys on this ever. Ever.
And the practice of worshiping
on Sunday, the first day was understood
by the Protestant reformers, lots of
them.
Gearlam Mozanki, Hinrich Wolf, Nicholas
Bound, and on and on and on. They all
understood new creation. They all
understood the larger role the Sabbath
plays in the entirety of redemptive
history and that it's ultimately about
pointing to Jesus and the gospel. But as
per usual folks,
we have another Adventist pastor who is
simply paraphrasing Ellen White without
mentioning her, bringing her commentary
to the text, then asserting that that's
what the text is saying because he has
God's inspired interpretation of such.
Notice last day events, page 136.
Quote,
"The so-called Christian world is to be
the theater of great and decisive
actions. Men in authority will enact
laws controlling the conscience after
the example of the papacy.
Babylon will make all nations drink of
the wine of the wrath of her
fornication. Every nation will be
involved. There will be a universal bond
of union, one great harmony, a
confederacy of Satan's forces.
Insert out of context proof text. Now,
and shall give their power and strength
unto the beast.
Thus is manifested the same arbitrary
oppressive power against religious
liberty, freedom to worship God
according to the dictates of conscience
as was manifested by the papacy when in
the past it persecuted those who dared
to refuse to conform with the religious
rights and ceremonies of Romanism. Close
quote.
So by world stage, Mr. Lomachang is
referring to what Ellen White called the
so-called Christian world which will be
the great theater where the final
showdown is going to take place. Notice
so-called Christian.
By antir coalition he means what Ellen
calls here the confederacy of Satan's
forces.
Every nation is going to eventually be
involved in this and will concede total
power and control to the Roman Catholic
papacy which will will result in an
attack on freedom of conscience and
worship.
And all of this is supposedly a plain
thus sayeth the Lord in Revelation 16.
Yeah. No.
Again, testimonies for the church volume
quote.
When Protestantism shall stretch her
hand across the Gulf to grasp the hand
of the Roman power, when she shall reach
over the abyss to clasp hands with
spiritualism, when under the influence
of this three-fold union, our country
shall repudiate every principle of its
constitution as a Protestant and
republican government, and shall make
provision for the propagation of papal
falsehoods and delusions. Then we may
know that the time has come for the
marvelous working of Satan, and that the
end is near. Close quote.
Mr. Lom McCain, none of that is a is
plain in what you read from Revelation
anywhere in the whole book of
Revelation.
You say this because you think these
quotes are inspired commentary that give
you guys the green light from God that
your interpretation is bulletproof.
Thus, it's supposedly plain.
Which is also why this is what the SDA
Bible commentary says. It is coming from
Ellen White when no, we don't accept
that.
We don't accept that at all.
We don't accept your assumptions, nor do
we accept your twisting of this text.
None of what you claimed is in
Revelation 16:16 because it uses the
term Armageddon. You guys sound like
Jehovah's Witnesses.
And myself and countless others totally
reject your denuting of the book of
Revelation from history, making most of
the book irrelevant to those it was
originally written to. Chapter and verse
divisions are not inspired. They are a
1550s addition to the text. So nice try,
but not going to cut it. He said,
"Apostate Protestantism is building a
bridge with Roman Catholicism and
elevating worship that makes people feel
good and downplays truth that makes one
uh uh one's character to be good." Just
laughable.
Christian, get used to this claim from
Adventists. It's one of their favorite
false dichotoies
or what's called the false dilemma
fallacy. There's only these two options.
They think that when you reject their
false understanding of the role that
obedience plays in the life of a
believer, that means you don't think
Christ actually changes people when they
come to him.
Mr. Lom King, this is so utterly false
and you guys really need to stop saying
this, especially when people like myself
who had very radical conversions yet
completely reject Adventism on
theological grounds.
Has nothing to do with not being
changed.
And the irony of this is that if you
actually understood new creation, you'd
understand that that doctrine doesn't
just cover why the Christian church
worships on the new memorial day of the
new creation, but that Christ makes his
people new creatures in him, which
entails not only behavior modification
and changes in a person's desires, but
it actually changes an aspect of their
being.
Yes, Protestants affirm a changed life
when coming to Christ. Yes, Roman
Catholics affirm the same.
Yes, the church in the the the churches
in the east,
they affirm the same thing. It's
baffling that you guys try and pull this
stunt and keep people in Adventism
diluted. It's like, if I could roll my
eyes any harder, I might pull a cornea.
Protestants reject your guys' false
belief that obedience maintains
maintains a person's righteous standing
before God.
This is because we recognize that we
still live in fallen flesh that has to
be mortified daily. Like John Owen said,
"Be killing sin or it'll be killing
you."
That is a daily war. No, you're not
going to get out of it until
glorification or until you die before
then and then are resurrected.
And until that happens, resurrection and
glorification, our fallen flesh
is going to war.
There are good days, there are bad days.
But despite this, we continue waring
because God is faithful and sustains us.
But when you believe like the SDA church
teaches
that no change of character and
disposition will happen when Christ
returns or in the resurrection,
as Ellen White plainly claimed. Again,
we've looked at that before. You can go
to our website and look at that as well.
It makes sense that you wouldn't
understand this, but no, it's like St.
Augustine said, we're to daily cry out
to God for the strength to overcome. He
actually was he also believed that you
should be praying the Lord's prayer
regularly and daily because he actually
understood that in the Lord's prayer,
you're to ask forgiveness for your sins.
And it's a daily prayer.
But either way, he he he essentially
said something to the effect of we're to
daily cry out to God for the strength to
overcome the flesh because in and of
ourselves, we can't do it. And when it
happens, because God does give the
strength to do it, there's no room for
boasting because we know that it was
only by the strength given from God that
one is able to overcome that.
still recognizing though that there's
good days and bad days because
Augustine, like the rest of Christians
in history, didn't have this very
truncated view of sin like the SDA
church does. The problem is in Adventist
theology, every time a person fails,
despite their best efforts, they're
freshly condemned again and need to get
back into right standing with God
through Christ's work in the heavenly
sanctuary in the investigative judgment.
So, the problem isn't obedience. It
isn't the law of God. It's your guys's
unlawful handling of such and twisting
them to fit with your convoluted system
of theology. That's the problem. So,
please stop lying and saying that
Protestants don't believe in obedience
or a changed life. I am so sick of
hearing this.
So beyond sick of hearing this, and we
looked at some in part one, and we could
spend the whole night on this, but
please stop with this. I want to tell
you the issues of the past are the
issues of the future. Polarization will
lead you to stand on one side or the
other. Everybody in the final showdown
is going to be on God's side or on the
devil's side. What happened? What was
the issue on Mount Carmel? That is going
to be the same issue in the last days.
Look at First Kings chapter 18 and verse
21.
First Kings chapter 18 and verse 21. And
the Bible says, "And Elijah came to all
the people and said, here's the issue.
How long will you falter between two
opinions?" And here is the crux of the
issue. If the Lord is God, follow him.
But if Baal, follow him. And what was
the response? But the people answered
him not a word. They couldn't say
anything. Why? Because you have Ahab and
Jezebel saying, "Hold your ground." And
you have Elijah seemingly to be helpless
standing by himself. But friends, you
know what happened? God was about to
show up on Mount Carmel. You know this,
he said, "The issues of the past are the
issues of the future." Again, more Ellen
White without crediting her than just
claiming it's from the Bible. Notice
again, folks,
last day events, page 147.
Quote, "The persecution of Protestants
by Romanism by which the religion of
Jesus Christ was almost annihilated,
will be more than rivaled when
Protestantism and popery are combined."
Close quote. So, the persecution of
Protestants by Rome during the 16th and
17th centuries will be rivaled when
Protestants and Roman Catholicism link
arms in the supposed anti-truth
coalition.
This is what he's talking about
regarding issues of the past. Again in
Marinatha she writes
quote
the scriptures teach that popery is to
regain its lost supremacy and that the
fires of persecution will be rekindled
through the timeserving concessions the
so-called pro of the so-called
Protestant world in this time of peril
we can stand only as we have the truth
and the power of God
the prospect of being brought into
personal danger and distress need not
cause dispos uh dispos I hate this word
dispondency, but should quicken the
vigor and hopes of God's people. That's
the SDAs.
For the time of their peril is the
season of uh for God to grant them clear
manifestation of his power. Close quote.
No. Scripture nowhere plainly claims
poperry is going to regain its lost
supremacy and will again at the behest
of the so-called Protestant world give
concession for that to happen.
This is the great controversy theme
again doing the interpreting by reading
into the text a foreign worldview that
the scriptures do not teach.
But again, this is what he means when he
talks about past issues
being future issues. Yet none of this is
a plain thus sayeth the Lord. It is for
Adventists because Ellen White's
writings are a plain thus sayeth the
Lord, but it's not in the Bible. He
mentions the final showdown and two
sides in the end. Again,
Mr. Lomang, your charge here is coming
from Ellen White, not scripture.
Yes, there are most certainly two sides.
The kingdom of light and the kingdom of
darkness. But what you guys mean is that
these two sides are defined by seventh
day sabotarianism. Yet again, notice
what Ellen White wrote, folks. Great
controversy, page 605.
quote,
"The Sabbath will be the great test of
loyalty, for it is the point of truth
especially controverted. When the final
test shall be brought to bear upon men,
then the line of distinction will be
drawn between those who serve God and
those who serve him not. While the
observance of the false Sabbath in
compliance with the law of the state
contrary to the fourth commandment will
be in a vowel of allegiance to a power
that is in opposition to God. The
keeping of the true Sabbath in obedience
to God's law is an evidence of loyalty
to the creator.
While one class by accepting the sign of
submission to earthly powers receive the
mark of the beast, the other choosing
the token of allegiance to divine
authority receive the seal of God. Close
quote.
The scriptures nowhere claim this. No,
it isn't a plain thus sayith the Lord
that the pope is going to re regain
power and the final dividing line
between those who are saved and the seal
of go and get the seal of God are those
who go to church on Saturday.
This is the SDA church's interpretation
of the text, an apocalyptic passage of
scripture, mind you.
And because Ellen White said it, that
means God has placed his stamp of
approval on it and it's coming from him.
Notice how Mr. Lomachang doesn't mention
Ellen White at all.
And this is why Adventists will say
stuff. My My pastor never mentions Ellen
White. Yeah, he doesn't need to. doesn't
mean it doesn't mean she's not still
driving the car. And this is a perfect
example of such. He's monologuing and
paraphrasing Ellen White's claims, then
supplementally sprinkling in verses of
scripture from all over the place, and
then claiming it's just it's just a
plain thus sayith the Lord.
Just everyone just missed this before
the SDAs. That's the mentality. We know
the Bible. Everyone else is ignorant.
They're all confused. They don't We're
the We're the beacon of light in the
mass of confusion. That's the undertones
here, folks. If you've never been in
SDA, you may not you may not catch that
or understand, but that's what's going
on here. It's this mentality that we're
God has given us this great amount of
light that no one else has. This extra
two million words and we're going to be
held more accountable and it's our duty
to enlighten all these other ignorant
Christians that they they would believe
like we do if if they just ever
encountered an Adventist. uh it's not
their fault. You know, they try to
soften it, but you know, but if you hear
it, oh man, and and you take umbrage
with it up, well, you must just not be
one of the the the ones. You you're just
not meant to to be to to make it because
anyone who accepts the message, well,
you know, that's those are the true
people that God's calling out of of of
the world. That's what's going on here.
First Kings 18 says nothing about the
7th day Sabbath being the final dividing
line in the end times and those who
don't heed the SDA church's call to come
join them in worship on Saturday are
siding with Satan by doing so. Not a
lick of that is in the text nor is first
kings a picture of the end times. This
is called isog Jesus. He's not exeding
or expositing any scripture here.
So Protestants are supposedly saying,
"Hold your ground." And Elisha, the SDA
church, is seemingly standing by
themselves as the outcasts,
you know, with the truth, trying to to
to warn everyone. That's what he's
trying to say is a valid application of
First Kings 18. When you handle the
Bible like this, you demonstrate you can
make the Bible say anything. And people
do. There's all sorts of unsound wild
biblical theories out there and they all
use the same method of interpretation to
try and read themselves into the Bible.
So now he's going to give a cliffnotes
of the experience of Elisha on Mount
Carmel and he's going to say there was
something God wanted Elisha to restore.
So pay close attention to how he tries
weasling Ellen White and the SDA church
into the biblical text. But let me go
ahead and walk you through it. What was
happening? There's something that God
wanted Elijah to do. There was something
that God wanted Elijah to restore
because Ahab and Jezebel in their false
alliance in their apostate relationship
began to disintegrate everything that
represented true worship. So what did
God demand Elijah to do? First Kings
chapter 18 and verse 30, look what God's
word says.
Then Elijah said to all the people,
"Come near to me." God is saying, "Come
near to those who teach the truth." And
then the Bible says, "So all the people
came near to him." And what did Elijah
do? And he repaired the altar of the
Lord that was broken down. What?
Elijah repaired the altar of the Lord
that was broken down.
Now, let me just pause for a moment and
take that to the place that it needs to
go. In these last days, there are many
things that exist in Christianity that
are broken down. But people, for numbers
of reasons, some just don't know, some
have never heard. Others have followed
traditions of ancestor to ancestor, a
family line of worship. And some people
have truly found an honest, Godloving,
Christ growing relationship. And they
have not yet been exposed to the certain
truths of God's word that if they were,
they would definitely embrace it. But
what happens when the altar is broken
down that no one can worship there? So
before true worship is restored, the
altar that has been broken down has to
be rebuilt. In times of apostasy, truth
must be rebuilt, raised up, repaired,
and restored. And friends, one of those
things that need to be restored are
brought out in the book of Isaiah,
chapter 58, 12-4.
Notice what the Bible says. Isaiah
58:12-14.
Those from among you shall build the old
waste places. You shall raise up the
foundations of many generations. And you
shall be called the repairer of the
breach, the restorer of streets to dwell
in. Notice, rebuild, raise up, repair,
restore. What is he talking about? Look
at verse 13.
If you turn away your foot from the
Sabbath, from doing your pleasure on my
holy day, and call the Sabbath a
delight, the holy day of the Lord,
honorable, and shall honor him, not
doing your own ways, nor finding your
own pleasures, nor speaking your own
words. Then you shall delight yourself
in the Lord. and look at the promise.
And I will cause you to ride on the high
hills of the earth and feed you with the
heritage of Jacob your father. Why? The
mouth of the Lord has spoken.
So Ahab and Jezebel and their apostate
relationship began to disintegrate
everything that represented true
worship. He says, so remember in his
analogy here, his typological
esqueological, you know, thing he's
trying to draw to this, as you notice,
they read all of scripture in light of
esquetology and make everything in the
Bible. I mean, they make Genesis about
esquetology in in in the the primary
sense, but nevertheless, remember Ahab
supposedly represents Protestants.
Jezebel supposedly represents the Roman
Catholic harlot, and the SDA church is
Elisha. Mr. Lom King again Protestants
never agreed with you guys on the 7th
day Sabbath.
Your talk is about apostate
Protestantism saying that Protestants
have gone apostate because they're
linking up with Romanism and accepting
Babylonian teachings supposedly quote
unquote first generation Protestants
the earliest we can go to. They never
agreed with you on this and that's what
you're claiming is being restored.
This has nothing to do with the papacy,
Roman Catholicism, or any of the other
conspiracies that you guys claim.
So, how did Protestants disintegrate
true worship, aka 7th day
Sabbathkeeping?
Because like we saw in part one, the
conundrum of this whole narrative is
that by your own definition, sir, first
generation Protestants were never
Protestant.
They were apostates from the start. Yet,
your church's own scholars claim the SDA
church is an heir of the Protestant
reformers, as we looked at.
This is the problem. When you weave a
web of ridiculous theories together
based on the statements of a third grade
educated woman in the 19th century in
North America and take it as being from
God, you end up doing severe severe
damage to the sacred scriptures. Another
perfect example of this, he claimed in
First Kings 18:30, God is saying to draw
near to those who teach the truth. Well,
Mr. Lomma King, then we definitely
shouldn't be drawing near to Adventism.
I I I I think you guys get so tunnel
visioned
on the Sabbath and forget that isn't
unique to you guys whatsoever.
Even if we granted 7th day sabotarianism
to Adventism, which I don't, but even if
we did,
that doesn't validate Adventism.
That doesn't justify your false gospel.
That doesn't justify the Adventist idol
God. It doesn't validate your guys's
lack of word and sacrament ministry. It
doesn't validate synergism or hyperree
willism, your lack of law gospel
distinction, the health message, the
investigative judgment, the sanctuary.
Ellen White being a false prophet that
blasphemed God constantly and all the
other things that are off in Adventism.
Nor does it validate the Sabbath
supposedly being the seal of God and the
dividing line in the end, which is
what's actually novel to you all amongst
the seventh day Sabotarian groups.
You guys have so many theological
problems, yet you constantly beat the
seventh day Sabbath drone because the
third angel's message to try and drown
out all of that, including that if even
if you can convince us of seventh day
sabotarianism being valid,
that doesn't make Adventism valid. Not
even close. He claims the altar of the
Lord that was broken down is a type or
picture of the seventh day Sabbath which
was broken down and needed to be
repaired and restored. Again, this is
not a plain thus sayeth the Lord. In
First Kings 18,
Elijah prepared a literal altar,
erected a literal altar for God to
demonstrate that he's the true God
amongst the pagan false gods. God then
sent fire down to consume that altar
after it was dowsted with water, which
was a demonstration to the pagans who
had a a a false god. again, not the true
God, but believed false things about
him, an actual false god that Elisha ser
and it demonstrated that Elisha served
the the true and living God. They do
this a lot and they're not alone in
this. I just had a lady this week sent
me this long write up about casting
stones and and the woman the prick
adultery, the woman caught in adultery.
It's like despite the textual variant
issues with that, those were literal
stones, not metaphorical word stones.
like, oh, that that story is about
casting, you know, judgment on someone.
No, it's not. The law called for people
to be literally stoned for adultery.
It's not metaphorical word stones. But
to draw out of this an analogy for the
altar being a doctrine that needed to be
restored in the end times so that people
can worship God correctly is not only
bizarre, but it's just false. That's not
what First Kings is teaching us.
He claims, you know, some just don't
know about the Sabbath truth, like I
mentioned earlier, which is what they
call it, the Sabbath truth, while others
have simply followed tradition, just
like we heard Doug Bachelor and Mark
Finley assert on the same topic.
But notice, when you hear the SDA
message about the Sabbath, you have to
make a life or death decision. If you
haven't heard it, you're saved in
ignorance. And we've looked at that
multiple times from their fundamental
beliefs book, their website, their
pastors, their scholars, etc. This is
always the excuse if you reject this
whole un extra biblical uh uh uh
narrative which he's weaving here which
is ultimately great controversy fiction
and not what scripture is actually
saying. Mr. Lomachang,
it would do you well to study the
Protestant re the reformers and the
reformation and what they actually
understood and believed.
You guys appeal to this a lot to try and
make it sound like your small little
sliver of the world
isn't the only, you know, you're not the
only true Christians.
Yet your claims don't actually align
with history or reality. The Protestant
reformers that you claim to be heirs of
as true Protestants and the rest of us
have gone apostate, they wrote on the
seventh day Sabbath, sir. They were not
ignorant on this or in the dark like you
guys try and paint it. They rejected it
and rightly so. So your ignorance excuse
doesn't work on them, which backfires on
your whole talk here.
You're claiming the Protestant re You're
claiming that apost Protestantism has
gone apostate. And I I get what they're
trying to say with this. Like, well, the
Sabbath truth light didn't come until
later on. So they, you know, the the
reformers didn't have it. No, that's not
true.
They weren't ignorant on this, which
we're going to see momentarily.
Which is why you guys have to then
appeal to statements of Ellen White that
we've looked at before regarding the
Sabbath test only being a present truth
test and that those that died before it
uh uh are are resting in hope now, even
though she contradicted herself, as we
saw in part one, by saying that the
Sabbath has been a test of loyalty in
all generations.
Just like claiming Christians are
against obedience and a changed life
upon coming to Christ, you guys really
need to stop this lie, too. Everyone was
not in the dark on the Sabbath until you
guys came along. For example, like I
said, let's look at some of the
reformers here, folks.
First, Geralam Zanki, Italian reformer.
Here's what he writes about the Sabbath
in his what?
Treatise on the fourth commandment.
Get this, folks. Adventists, former
Adventists, questioning Adventists.
Everyone was not confused and in the
dark on the Sabbath prior to the SDA
church being raised up by God to
enlighten everyone. Notice what he says.
quote, "If for the memory of our
redemption, one day in a week is to be
celebrated,
that's a memorial, and our redemption
was perfected on the day that followed
the Jews Sabbath, which is called the
Lord's, then upon just consideration was
the sanctification of the Sabbath
removed unto the Lord's day."
upon what day the church should meet for
public worship of God is set down by the
tradition of the apostles
and that is out of controversy among all
the learned. Ah, everyone knows this
goes back to the apostles. He's saying,
"For although we have no express
commandment from the apostles in plain
words for keeping holy of the Lord's
day, aka it's not a verbatim statement
like the SDA church likes to often
claim." Where? Show me one verse like we
saw with Doug Bachelor. Show me one
verse that says, "Well, that's not how
it's arrived at, sir. And you guys don't
use that same standard for your
teachings either. You only do this on
the Sabbath because you think it's a
good defense." He continues,
"Yet we doubt not, but that it is their
tradition, the apostles, because St.
John makes mention of it." He cites
Revelation 1:10. "And why does he call
it the Lord's day, even of that custom
that was already received among the
Christians?"
Because that our Lord Jesus by rising
again upon that day did finish our
salvation. That's redemption. For he
rose again for our justification, as the
apostle says, Romans 4:25, and did as it
were, make a new world
when he renewed all things. Close quote.
Ah, new creation.
It's one of the marching beats of this
platform.
These were teachings of Protestant
thought, sir.
Meaning, it wasn't just an isolated
case.
This is what classical Protestants have
taught, depending on the branch of the
Reformation, for long before you guys
were around.
And it wasn't unique to them.
Master Zanki stood on the shoulders of
giants and recognized that this is a
2,000-year-old understanding, not some
modern construct. This isn't novel to
the 1600s,
1500s. They had a robust theology around
the new creation, something Adventist
theology does not understand at all. And
if you did, your whole narrative would
collapse because you'd realize that
worship on the first day has nothing to
do with the Pope or Romanism. The same
people you guys applaud for standing up
to Roman hierarchy were supposedly
lackey for the papal Sabbath, as you
guys call it. I mean, give me a break.
Another
Hinrich Wolf.
He was a professor of Hebrew in Zurich,
Switzerland during the Reformation.
Notice what he writes.
Sorry, I forgot to update the slide
there where it says treatise on the
fourth commandment. That's a that's not
his work on this.
He said, quote, "Christ did appoint the
new Sabbath. when our last enemy, death,
being overcome, he made an end of the
labors of our redemption, which in his
humanity were to be born. And the next
day, with the new man restored, he
brought out of the grave a new time, the
time of our redemption and of the new
covenant, and did prepare an everlasting
Sabbath, into the which himself then
entered. for us also at the time
appointed by virtue of his resurrection
to be entered into.
Therefore,
as in the time of the creation, talking
about Genesis, the original creation,
that day which was first of the creation
finished was made holy for the worship
of God. So now in the time of
redemption,
that day which is first after the
finishing of it is to be accounted holy
of us. Close quote.
Nothing to do with not understanding
some special knowledge that SDAs have
supposedly been given that no one else
was able to to see from scripture.
You guys claim it's a plain thus sayeth
the Lord. Yet everyone was supposedly in
the dark on this until God raised the
7th Day Adventist Church up and decided
to reveal it through Ellen White to the
world. So many holes and inconsistencies
in these claims. No, Wolfus understood
new creation just like Zoni and other
reformers. Again, here let's look at
another classical Protestant reformer,
Nicholas Bound. This is his his area of
specialty. His whole theological focus
was on Sabbath.
and he's he he's written arguably the
most extensive Protestant treatis on the
subject of the Sabbath in history. Was
he completely ignorant of the seventh
day Sabbath and why the church worship
worships universally on the first day?
Quote,
it's from his book, The True Doctrine of
the Sabbath.
He makes this day, talking about the
first day, among all the holy days of
the Christians, not only chief in
account, but first in time. For when all
the Jewish holy days ended at the death
of Christ, then this began, even at the
time of his resurrection. And the
sacrament of the Lord's supper did no
more merely succeed the Passover.
Let me say that again. Sorry. And the
sacrament of the Lord's supper did no
more nearly succeed the Passover which
was ordained at the same supper in the
end of the administration of the former
than this Lord's day does the old
Sabbath which began when that ended.
And so it has its appribation not only
from later times but even from the
writings of the apostles
wherein we see it named and observed.
So that though the Christian emperors as
Constantine and others as appears in the
imperial laws did certain hundreds of
years after Christ make laws for the
establishing of it whereby it was more
generally uh generally received. Yet it
was both observed of the church long
before and had better warrant than from
those emperors even from the apostles
themselves. Close quote.
This is from the chapter titled Why the
Change from the Seventh to the First?
No. Protestants were not ignorant on
this subject in need of God to raise up
a third grade educated woman in the 19th
century to correct everyone with some
special insight like a Gnostic that
everyone else before them missed such
that the Sabbath altar needed
resurrected by the end times by by this
end times movement. This is silly.
And as we've looked at numerous times,
including last week, bound reiterates
what we saw in Dr. Schoff's history of
the Christian church that Constantine
made a civil provision for the first day
which was distinct and separate from the
uh the religious aspect which was being
observed long before Constantine and
goes back to the apostles. Constantine
simply made something legal. It
protected Christians. That's what it was
about. not changing anything.
And bound rightly points out that in the
new covenant, the old covenant form of
Passover takes on a new covenant form in
the ceremonial aspect. It's the Lord's
supper. The same is true of the seventh
day Sabbath. The new covenant form is
the first day, the day that Jesus
accomplished redemption and the
redeeming of the creation that fell into
sin. I've gone over this at great
lengths in other streams, so I will
leave that there. This was foretold in
Genesis. You want to make an
esqueological application, there you go,
Mr. Lomck. Something that's actually
speaking into future events, a promise
of God, the new creation, the new
covenant, etc. The foretelling of the
Messiah, Genesis 3:15, who would come
and destroy the works of the devil, 1
John 3:8, inaugurate a new creation by
redeeming it. That is a valid
application because that's the actual
context that that's being said in not
you reading into first kings a
historical narrative and then trying to
say now this is a picture of the end
times. No, it's not. And Adventists need
to stop saying everyone was in the dark
on this and ignorant, which is why
virtually everyone before them disagreed
with their faulty understanding of the
text. Please, it's not true. Not at all.
that people reject your guys's teaching
because they just haven't heard it.
That like that may rally up the troops.
That may rally up Adventists to think,
"Oh, yeah, we need to really hit the
grounds and and and and evangelize the
people." No. No.
Now, I know this is not going to stop
Adventists from just paring this, but
it's a falsehood and according to John
Lomang means they have a false god
because he said any false doctrine means
you have a false Christ and worship God
falsely. He cited Isaiah 58:12-14,
John, where is again back to the thesis
for tonight. Where in anything that you
read
was that a plain thus sayeth the Lord?
Where in what you read did we hear that
Isaiah is typologically speaking about
the end times when a group of
anti-trinitarian anti-gosspel heretics
who claim the entire church went
apostate would rise up restore the
fullness of the gospel as well as the
truth about the seventh day Sabbath
because everyone has been in the dark on
this.
Where did it say anything about what you
read being typological of the end times
when the final dividing line between
those who worship God and those who who
who worship him not will be if they have
the seal of of the seventh day Sabbath.
It doesn't
because it uses the word Sabbath. You
feel justified in your claims. You
simply read three verses and then
inserted a bunch of Ellen White details
that aren't found in the text. But you
think that you're being biblical because
she supposedly is God's messenger who
sheds infallible light onto the text.
Yet nothing in the text says it's
typological about the end times.
I mean seriously I think I I think
people like like this gentleman I'm not
going to say all SDAs obviously but I
think people like John Lomccang their
mind has been basted and seeped in
advent in Adventist literature Ellen
White writings etc so much that the
divid ironically the dividing line
between Ellen White and scripture is
completely non-existent
because the text said none of that the
idea that a person would ever come to
that conclusion based on what you're
saying, based on reading the text is,
I'm going to say virtually zero. Now,
that doesn't mean that it's not present
because the standard person can't
understand it. But the point being,
everyone missed it before you guys. You
have some special Gnostic insight that
no one else has.
No,
the dividing line between those who
worship God and those who don't is
absolutely God's seal. I agree. I agree.
And Christian, you should too. But that
seal isn't the seventh day Sabbath like
you guys teach. It's the Holy Spirit
being born again.
In my honest opinion, when Adventists
deliberately ignore Ephesians 1:13 and
exclusively point to Ephesians 4:30 to
try and say, "No, no, no. The Holy
Spirit's the one doing the sealing."
It shows that either they know they're
wrong and don't want to accept it.
They're ignorant of Ephesians 1:13 or
they're dishonest. Those are the three
options because Ephesians 1:13 says the
Holy Spirit is the seal. Not just that
he does the ceiling. This is a both and
situation. Again, don't use the false
dilemma fallacy. It's not an eitheror.
He is both the one who does the sealing
and the seal itself.
Because Paul says, "When you heard the
word of truth, the gospel of your
salvation, and believed, you were sealed
with
the Holy Spirit."
Adventist friend with. Say it with me.
With sealed with the Holy Spirit.
This is milk level understanding. Babes
in Christ can understand this with. If I
seal the door with tape, what did I seal
the door with? Tape.
That means the spirit is the seal. And
yes, Ephesians 4:30, 2 Corinthians 1:22-
24.
They say that the spirit does the
sealing also. It's a both and, not an
eitheror.
But now, so pay attention here, folks.
He's going to tell a story similar to
what we heard from Doug Bachelor a
couple weeks ago. Pay very close
attention.
I've heard this from a number of SDAs,
people in my own immediate family, a
number of people. So, this is an
interesting uh uh telling of Mr.
Lomang's experience of this, but pay
very close attention. And this story is
supposed to be anecdotal support for
this narrative that he's laying out.
Okay,
let me pause for a brief moment and
insert a story here. When I was a young
man in the dish jockey world, partying,
gambling, pool hustling, I lost my
spiritual center, the lady who raised me
in the church when I was about 12 years
old. At 13 years old, I went out into
the streets of New York City, gambling,
partying, pool hustling, living the
night life. But a young lady came into
my life at about 16 years old. She's my
wife today of more than 37 years.
And she reintroduced me to the God I
forgot. She began to rebuild, raise up,
repair, and restore the broken down
places of my life. But I was not yet
convinced that that was the direction I
wanted to go. So I began to go from
church to church. And the big issue that
I was struggling over was the Sabbath.
So I went to three different
denominations. I won't mention them. And
I asked three different pastors from
three different key churches in my
community about the Sabbath. I was a
young man. One pastor walked me up the
steps down the hallway to the outdoor
steps of the church and told me never to
return. I was attending a youth group. I
was asking him, "Pastor, could you tell
me about the Bible Sabbath?" He told me
never come back. I went to another
church across the street from my house,
a large charismatic church. The pastor
was very wellknown. I said, "Would you
tell me about what the Bible says about
the Sabbath?" And to my surprise, he was
able to unfold the historical outlay of
how the Sabbath got changed. He
mentioned the dates. He mentioned who
changed it. And then he says, "Wait
right here. I'll be right back." And he
left me in that office for 45 minutes
and never came back. And I walked out of
his office disappointed because I
thought since he knows so much, maybe
he's going to come back and give me some
clue on how I could restore my
relationship with Christ by honoring
what he confirmed was in fact
scriptural. And then I went to a third
church. And the pastor there
said to me, "Of course, our church
changed the Sabbath." And he mentioned
when they did it. And then he said to
me, "But we are too far gone today to
turn back." And I want to tell you
friends, that ignited in me a
restoration, a rebuilding, a raising up,
a repairing of something that had been
broken down in my life.
So, I'm not saying he's lying because I
obviously wasn't there for these
encounters,
but I personally do not believe him.
Folks, comment down below. Do you buy
that? Seriously?
the the way it was was was portrayed
there.
This story sounds way too editorialized
with SDA assumptions to just be an
onthe-fly sort of thing.
He very clearly encountered SDA talking
points, which he claims his wife
reintroduced him to the God he once knew
and said that he he left the church. I'm
assuming he's talking about the SDA
church.
And I'm going to guess his his now wife
was a Seventh Day Adventist. Either way,
he was struggling over the issue of the
Sabbath. He then went out and did what,
like I said, I've heard countless people
claim they did. Oh, I tried all the
denominations in my town.
And they took the SDA talking points
that the SDA church gave them and went
to various local churches. And because
they encountered people who couldn't
give them a sufficient response, that
somehow vindicates Adventism.
for them that was enough to vindicate
the SDA church and demonstrate that
they're right and everyone else is
confused.
So he says he went to to three different
denominations
and they'll go unnamed. The first he
says he asked the pastor at youth group
about the Sabbath and was told to never
return. Again, I'm sorry. I I just Mr.
Lom King, I'm not I'm not saying you're
lying. Maybe you're not. I I just don't
buy this. I don't believe that a
Christian pastor because you simply
asked a question about the Sabbath, he
walked you to the front steps of the
building and said to never come back.
Like seriously,
we want to start doing skits on this
this channel. This is the sort of stuff
you make skits about.
Like what? Because you asked a hard
question, he took you to the front
steps.
There are way too many missing details
for this to even make sense. But even
so, let's say that's what happened. So
what? How does that justify your use of
Isaiah and First Kings? This is all
anecdotal experience and hasty
generalization. The second obviously a
megaurch type assembly. And the pastor
told him all about the history of the
Sabbath, why it was changed, etc., and
then left him alone in the office for 45
minutes to never be seen again.
John, again, I'm not buying this. Not
that I think you care if I do or not.
You probably never see this. But I don't
believe that a Christian pastor sat down
with you, admitted that the papacy
changed the Sabbath, which is obviously
what you mean by the the history of its
change, and then just left you in the
office alone for 45 minutes to then just
leave on your own.
You were hoping he would return and give
you some clue on how to restore your
relationship with Christ, what you
believed was to be done through
observing the seventh day old creation
Sabbath memorial.
That's what I mean. These encounters
sound far too lopsided in favor of
preconceived avenous notions to just
naturally occur. Just my opinion. But
then the third the the third person very
clearly a Roman Catholic a priest
because he said they admitted to
changing the Sabbath.
Yet Mr. Lom King like every other SDA
you do not understand what Rome means
when they claim this. And it's a
principle now by the way folks
on Facebook anywhere. Whenever I see
this or hear this now on principle, I'm
going to correct it every single time.
And I don't care if SDA say, "Oh, you're
you're defending Romanism. You're you're
you're a stoogge for Roman Catholicism."
Yeah, I'm one of those reformed
anathematized Roman Catholics. Yeah,
good one. No, it's on principle because
this lie that they use has bamboozled I
don't know how many people. So, we're
going to continue refuting this lie.
Okay?
This was a popularized statement that
Rome changed the the the Sabbath and
Protestants have no basis for it. They
love to quote the Catholic mirror and
all these, you know, Steven Keen's uh uh
catechism not understanding what they're
even quoting. Th was a popularized
statement in the post-reformation era in
response to Protestants
and it was in the larger context of
apostolic succession.
Okay, Christian, you have to understand
this to deal with these sorts of cult
groups.
If not, you'll be like, "What? What?
Huh?" Because they don't understand what
they're citing.
So, understand the statements that they
point to when they hear Rome say this.
They bring to this a bunch of
preconceived SDA ideas and think that
Rome is agreeing with them. Well, I'm
getting a hold of or ahead of myself.
Both parties, Protestants and Roman
Catholics, agree that the first day goes
back to the apostles just like we saw
from those the the statements of of
Master Zanki and Wolfus etc. The
argument became how does one have
apostolic origin?
Okay,
how does one go back to the apostles?
Because the charge from the Roman
Catholic Church against the reformers,
all the branches, English, the
Anglicans, Presbyterians, and the Swiss,
the Canton regions and and Geneva,
Germany with Luther and and Meenan.
Rome claims the apostles, this is their
system, they claim the apostles were the
first Roman Catholics.
And so to be separated from the Roman
institution,
if A equals B, then B equals C type
thing.
Rome claims the apostles were the first
Roman Catholics. So to be separated from
the Roman institution is to be cut off
from the apostles.
Thus they claim Protestants have no
basis for Sunday because we supposedly
don't go back to the apostles like they
do.
Yet Adventists will cite these
statements and then insert into it all
sorts of stuff that Rome's not saying
like that they're admitting the the Pope
did did what what what they claim. He's
the man of sin that Daniel prophesied
would change times and laws, etc. That's
not at all what Rome is saying. But it
doesn't stop Adventists from just
repeating this.
I don't believe for a second that this
Roman Catholic priest told you that
we're too far gone to turn back at this
point. As if the guy was admitting that
it's an error, but well, it's been too
long to correct it, which is like a
subtle like, see, look how tradition
overrides everything in in the Roman
church.
This flies in the face of their own
publicly stated teachings on the subject
and it has to do with the apostolic
origin of it as well as the new
creation.
And then Adventists when you point this
out then they'll try to use the genetic
fallacy. They'll just jump from fallacy
to fallacy to fallacy.
Oh well well when you say new creation
that's what that's what the Roman
Catholic Church says. Yeah. They believe
correct things friend. Get with the get
with the times.
get caught up to speed. Not everything
they believe is false.
The reformers were it's just it's crazy.
This talk is in the context of apostate
Protestantism. Yet this guy probably
doesn't even understand any of the
issues. He's just a great public speaker
who's been pumped out by the SDA machine
to go out and regurgitate all the same
talking points that we've heard for
decades.
You can find the evidence of the paper
trail all the way back to the pioneers.
This story feels so inserted into the
mix as anecdotal evidence to try and
validate the narrative that Christians
don't actually have an answer on this
topic. They're afraid of it and they all
know the SDA church is true. They just
don't want to admit it when they're
encountered with it.
Remember, it's just like Doug Bachelor
said. This story is way too similar to
Mr. Mr. Doug Bachelor. I went to three
local pastors in my town and because
none of them could give me an answer
that proves the SDA church is correct.
Mr. Lman, I don't know when this was
maybe, you know, before the days of the
internet. But even so, sir, this subject
has been this subject has been discussed
for 2,000 years. And there's lots of
theologians whose works you could have
consulted for a thorough explanation of
this. We just looked at one Nicholas
Bound's book,
folks. It's like 1,400 pages
to make the claim that he doesn't uh uh
consult scripture. It's just
Adventists, we want you to know the
truth. We want you to know the truth. I
don't want you to believe lies. I don't
like hearing people believe lies.
Believe it or not, pastors aren't
omnisient.
Believe it or not, scripture is vast and
broad and covers lots of topics and
subjects at varying degrees of depth and
complexity.
If I use the same standard, folks, the
same standard.
I do this frequently.
Former Adventists study here. Here
here's some homework from the platform.
Take it or leave it. Here's some
homework for you. study the difference
between an internal critique and an
external critique.
Very different things.
I love to apply the internal critique to
Adventism. When they make claims, the
first thing my mind will go to internal
critique. When they make a claim like
this,
I could use the same standard. You'd
have the same exact problem. Now, in
Adventism,
I've talked Mr. Lomachang. I've talked
with countless Adventist pastors over
the years. I've asked them all about the
sanctuary, for example, and the
investigative judgment. And you know
what? I hear drastically different
answers from all of them. That must
prove that Adventism is incorrect on the
teaching, right?
No, because that's a silly standard.
You would send me to consult with w with
with who you believe to be the most
qualified individuals on the subject.
Not just any SDA pastor of my choosing.
This is another case of rules for thee,
but not for we. One standard for
everyone else that if turned back in on
yourselves would result in the exact
same thing that you're criticizing
others for.
Nothing in that story, sir, proved that
the altar that Elijah erected is
typological of doctrine in the end times
that needs to be restored. Namely,
seventh day sabotarianism
because the truth of the teaching
disappeared and God raised you guys up
to repair it. None of that was a plain
thus sayeth the Lord. And the second
attack, the first attack was Satan in
heaven. But the second attack that
eventually resulted in attacking
Protestantism started through Rome.
Rome distorted the character of God
through its false doctrines in the dark
ages. Look at Daniel 7:25. And the Bible
said it would happen. The Bible says,
"He shall speak pompous words against
the most high." And that is the fourth
beast of Daniel. That dreadful, terrible
beast with iron teeth representing the
t-horned kingdom of Rome. It says, "He
shall speak pompet's words against the
most high shall persecute the saints of
the most high and shall intend to change
times and law. Then the saints shall be
given into his hand for a time and times
and half a time." And we know that to be
the 1260 years of the most severe
persecution ever faced by the Christian
church, the dark ages. During that time,
God's character and God's law were
attacked with a vicious attitude. But
you'll discover in God's word that his
character and his law are inseparable
and immutable. Meaning, you can't change
it. You can't change God's character and
you can't do a thing about the the
perpetuity and the longevity and the
permanent nature of his law which in
fact is a reflection of his character.
But the dark ages was an era when God
was associated with brutality
when those who worshiped then thought of
God as one who doesn't really care about
truth. God was associated with lies and
persecution. And some of those things
are too hideous to even talk about. If
you read the book Fox's Book of Martyrs,
you'll see what I'm talking about. God
was painted during the dark ages as a
vicious tyrant that eternally torments
those that disagree with him. And today,
there are still people that believe the
lie that Rome constructed. That people
burn endlessly when they forget that
even Satan himself is going to be
destroyed. try to measure that up. God
was seen as an exacting autocrat that
demanded allegiance. But God really, in
fact, doesn't demand allegiance. He
says, "Serve me if you love me." During
the dark ages, God was shown as an
oppressor of conscience and a thief of
liberty. Meaning, you don't have the
right to do anything other than what I
tell you. And that's not God. During the
dark ages, because men bowed to statues,
God was seen as cold and rigorous.
Because men were burned at the stake,
God was seen as angry and vengeful.
Because men were torn apart in dungeons,
God was seen as an unsatisfied,
salacious butcher of human life. And God
was worshiped out of fear and not out of
love. You see, whenever you don't follow
the principles of God's word, God's
character gets distorted. So, when
people think it doesn't matter what you
believe, everything you believe reflects
on the true character of Christ. He's
not a butcher. He's not angry and
vengeful. He's not cold and rigorous.
God doesn't force you to worship him. He
says, "If you love me,
keep my commandments." But for 1,260
years, Rome reigned, and in its ruthless
power, no one could stop them.
Okay, so more great controversy
filtering of history as well as just
outright fiction.
He alluded to Ellen White's claim that
Satan began attacking the character of
God, meaning the Ten Commandments in
heaven.
Their big thing is that God is
vindicating his character through things
like the investigative judgment, the
sanctuary service, etc. Yet, Mr.
Lomachang, you've stated multiple times
in this talk, namely during part one,
that if it isn't a plain thus sayeth the
Lord in scripture, it should be
rejected.
In fact, that's what you claimed is the
definition of being Protestant.
So, please show us a plain thus sayeth
the Lord of this occurring. Okay,
let's hear it. Adventist, comment down
below. Show us this in scripture. You're
not going to find it because scripture
nowhere says this. The Bible has very
little to say about Satan. It simply
says war broke out in heaven. Ezekiel
tells us Lucifer was jealous of God and
wanted to be the Almighty. Nothing about
him accusing the Ten Commandments and
seeking to set up his own system of
self-governance due to being jealous of
Jesus being taken into the councils of
God and not himself, etc.
All of that is great controversy fiction
that you secretly or quietly insert into
the text
but can't demonstrate from the text
itself.
And I think this is another case of of
an Adventist pastor crossing wires and
confusing Ellen White's writings with
scripture, which is a recurring problem
for some Adventists.
But then he says that the Roman Catholic
Church distorted the character of God
during the dark ages. And this is the
second attack of Satan against God. So
the first was Satan attacked God's law
in heaven before the earth was even
created and was jealous of Jesus being
taken into the councils of God and being
allowed to partake with God the Father
in the creation of the earth and yada
yada. The second attack was was this the
Catholic Church distorting the character
of God during the dark ages.
You guys are going to get sick of
hearing me say this, but it doesn't
change the facts.
Daniel 7:25 does not say that the
10-headed kingdom is Rome and that this
is in reference to the papacy
persecuting Christians. Adventists
believe that and that's fine. Believe
it. But it doesn't say what you plainly
claim.
You guys have an interpretation.
You need to own that. And you feel
strongly about that interpretation. I
get it. I get it.
Your entire system of theology is
dependent upon your guys' end times
theories. So I get it. I get it. Trust
me.
But you need to accept that you don't
have an infallible interpretation.
Okay,
you simply have an interpretation like
everyone else.
And the reason that esquetology has been
such a tricky subject through the
centuries is because it is advanced. It
has a lot of moving parts. It uses
symbolism. Apocalyptic literature is not
the same. Second piece of homework,
folks. Former Adventist, second piece of
homework.
study the different literary genres of
the Bible. While the Bible is one
library of books, those different books
are not all the same literary genre.
This matters
because there are certain understood
guidelines for reading certain genres of
literature. When it comes to a
apocalyptic literature such as Daniel,
Revelation, etc. There are certain
principles to rightly understand those
sorts of things. It's not the same as
reading uh Colossians,
Galatians, the pastoral epistles,
which those are not necessarily always a
onetoone when it comes to the gospels
because for example the gospels have
parables. You don't find parables in the
pastoral epistles. That's because of the
literary genre.
But I know Adventists think that they
have it all figured out and part of
their mission is to prophetically speak
into the Christian world. This is the
thing that we've been, you know, tasked
to provide to everyone else. We've got
this bulletproof prophetic
interpretation. But that doesn't change
the facts, folks. It doesn't change the
facts. You're in the same boat that
everyone else is. You haven't cracked
some code. you guys don't have some
gnostic level of understanding of the
text that gives you all the secrets and
shity about the future. You know these
claims they make. We're going to get
into this uh uh on Monday actually in
Monday's video. You know they have these
claims that um you know the the Bible
the Revelation and and Daniel they those
were closed books until the SDA church
came along. Ellen White writes about
this. you know, everyone in in their
day, they they just said, "Oh, you can't
even know that stuff." So, we don't even
study. That's that's the messaging and
the understanding that's been inherited
by lots of SDAs today.
Oh, they just don't even know. Folks,
there's commentaries on the book of
Revelation from the fifth and sixth
centuries.
It it just
I I pity 7th day Adventists.
The text does not plainly say what John
Lomccane claimed. It doesn't plainly say
what your prophetist claimed.
But because she claimed it
that well that's God speaking
infallibly.
He claimed the dark ages. During the
dark ages, Rome invented the idea of
hell being eternal conscious torment.
And people still erroneously believe
this lie today. Okay, folks, buckle up.
I'm not an apologist for hell, by the
way.
But when you make claims like this that
are just so demonstrably false,
understand that they have no clue what
they're talking about.
Disclaimer, I'm reformed.
No secret about that. From day one, I've
been public about this. I am a reformed
Christian.
I obviously agree abuses took place
during the medieval church.
But this is one of their favorite myths
to propagate to say Rome invented the
idea of eternal conscious torment to
tarnish the character of God. And it's a
lie. It's not true.
And this lie, they claim that that that
uh eternal conscious torment is is a
lie. And it's eternal conscious torment
that keeps a lot of people away from
God. This is a standard SDA claim. Plan,
if you're a Christian, plan on running
into this and hearing this. If you
engage apologetically with Adventists,
it is only a matter of time before you
hear this.
My God would never do those sorts of
things.
For starters, no, Mr. Lomang, that isn't
why people reject God.
You talk about needing to believe plain
thus sayeth the Lord beliefs. Well,
scripture gives you numerous ones on
this, sir. This is the problem with your
tunnel vision on the seven pillar
doctrines of Adventism.
you guys don't dig deep on all
theological topics, which is part of the
reason why I think Adventists are so
oftentimes in the dark on like when you
make a statement that if you don't
believe correct every single area, it
shows man, you don't understand how vast
the scriptures are. There's like so much
there, man.
But scripture gives you numerous reasons
as to why people reject God. And it's
not because of certain doctrines being
professed. Notice Jesus Christ himself.
Why does he state to Nicodemus that
people don't come to God?
This is John 3:16-21.
The most famous passage of all of
scripture. Look at the paricopy that
it's a part of having a discussion. He
he stoaltified that um Nicodemus doesn't
understand
the new birth. So earlier in John 3,
they're talking about the new birth and
he says, "You are the teacher, not a
teacher, the the definite article." He
says, "You're the teacher of Israel."
Meaning Nicodemus was not just a a Joe
Schmo pastor type figure.
You're the teacher of Israel and you
don't understand this. Well, he goes on
to essentially give Nicodemus the gospel
here. But notice what he says about why
people don't come to Christ.
Quote,
"For God so loved the world that he gave
his only son that whoever believes in
him should not perish but have eternal
life. For God did not send his son into
the world to condemn the world, but in
order that the world might be saved
through him. Whoever believes in him is
not condemned, but whoever does not
believe is condemned already because he
has not believed in the name of the only
son of God. And this is the judgment.
The light has come into the world and
people loved the darkness rather than
the light because their works were evil.
For everyone who does wicked things
hates the light and doesn't come to the
light. Why? Lest his works should be
exposed.
But whoever does what is true comes to
the light so that it may be clearly seen
that his works have been carried out in
God.
And thus the reading of God's holy word.
People don't come to Christ not because
they've been told God is a maniac or a
dictator, but because they love their
sin.
They don't want their sin to be exposed
and to turn from it. Full stop.
They can use various excuses, but then
Paul answers that in Romans 1.
Romans 1:18-2.
The whole book, Paul is laying out,
folks, an apologetic starting in Romans
1 about the condition that fallen man is
in. He explains because he's writing
primarily to Jews, but it's applicable
across the board. And he's explaining to
them that Gentiles and Jews are all in
the same boat. And he starts by laying
out the condition that man is in in
Romans 1 through3. He transitions in
Romans 4 through uh essentially seven to
discuss what the remedy to that is. But
in six and seven specifically, he talks
about uh essentially now rejoiners and
responses to what could potentially be
said to what he just laid out in
chapters 1-5.
So one one through three is discussing
the problem of of all of humanity. Paul
is laying out an apologetic here. Notice
what he says.
For the wrath of God is revealed from
heaven. That's present tense
against all ungodliness and
unrighteousness of men who by their
unrighteousness do what?
Suppress the truth.
For what can be known about God is plain
to them because God has shown it to
them.
For his invisible attributes, namely his
eternal power and divine nature, have
been clearly perceived ever since the
creation of the world in things that
have been made. So they are without
excuse.
For although they knew God,
they did not honor him as God or give
thanks to him. But they became futile in
their thinking and their foolish hearts
were darkened. Claiming to be wise, they
became fools and exchanged the glory of
the immortal God for images resembling
mortal man and birds and animals and
creeping things.
Therefore, God gave them up in the lust
of their hearts to impurity to the
dishonoring of their bodies amongst
themselves because they exchanged the
truth that go about God for a lie and
worshiped and served the creature rather
than the creator who is blessed forever.
Amen.
And thus the reading of God's holy word.
Paul explaining the slide of humanity
into fallenness.
He says that God's righteous uh judgment
on humanity is presently displayed in
the fact that they suppress the truth in
their unrighteousness, meaning their
sin.
The spiritually dead sinner loves their
They have no desire to turn to God.
They have what they want.
He then explains what is called by
theologians general revelation through
natural law. Nature itself testifies
that there's a creator.
No person in their right mind. I just I
I I this is me my own my own belief
here. No person in their right mind
would ever claim that an iPhone, for
example,
just happen to come together on its own
by random chance.
They would recognize, "No, it was made
by someone. It was designed."
So much more so. The trees, the stars,
human beings, which are all far more
complex than the iPhone.
This is why all people, yes, all people
are without excuse for denying God
because the evidence is so obviously
around you through general revelation.
But fallen man in his love for his sin
suppresses this truth by exalting the
creation to the level of creator to try
and mute the obvious truth and soothe
your conscience. It's like, how can you
go outside and look at the stars and
just think, "Oh, it's all just random
chance." No, dude. You're trying to soo
your conscience.
But that's exactly what we see in the
world. Whether it's pagan deities,
money, a certain lifestyle, whatever,
lost people replace the creator with
some aspect of creation to try and
bypass or shortcircuit the creator.
Every civilization, folks, study
history. Whether it's today or 5,000
years ago, people were doing the same
thing because there's an innate part of
humanity that has a an inkling and a
pull towards something outside and
bigger than themselves.
But in doing this, the ex exaltation of
the the creation over the creator, God
will eventually give people over to
their debased thinking and their minds
will become darkened. to the truth and
they become foolish.
So then he continues in the following
verses to explain the the deeper slide
that man falls into when they continue
in debauchery that men give up the
natural desire for the woman. He he's
he's talking about the the trajectory.
It just into sin. It just goes and goes
and goes and it just gets worse and
worse and God just eventually gives
people over to their debased thinking.
But all of that to say, no, Mr.
Lomachang people don't reject God
because someone told them hell is
eternal conscious torment and thus they
now have a tarnished view of the
character of God and want nothing to do
with him.
I don't doubt people have used that
excuse. They use all sorts of excuses.
But my point is the scriptures make
clear it's an excuse. It's not the real
issue. The real issue is that they're a
sinner.
They love their sin. They don't want the
light. They don't want Jesus. and on
judgment day using the excuse, well, God
was portrayed to me as an evil evil
tyrant. That's not going to cut it.
Now, as it pertains to eternal conscious
torment being invented by Rome in the
Middle Ages,
we've looked at another statement from
Doug Bachelor in the past, which is not
unique to him. Oh, the idea of of the
the the soul existing after death,
that's a creation of uh the dark ages.
That's a product of the dark ages.
we showed. No, it's not true.
I don't really care what your view of
hell is, by the way. I'm not an eternal
conscious torment apologist, like I
said. Meaning, if you reject it, that's
fine.
I affirm it. But that doesn't mean
someone isn't a Christian if they
disagree or hold to a a a conditional
position.
I've never harped on the SDA church for
their view in this area because I don't
think it's an issue that's that's
damnably heretical like their false
gospel and their false Christ are.
But when you make statements like this
slandering the Christian church
that are just totally false, we're going
to address them. Okay? He made a
historical claim.
Sometimes people will claim there's no
evidence of this belief prior to
Augustine in the fifth century. So,
we're going to explore sources only
prior to then, just like we did in the
Doug Bachelor video,
even though Augustine's day is like the
the turning point in infancy into the
dark ages.
So, even his statements on such prove
Mr. Lom King's claim is false.
Augustine's statements.
The other thing I'll say is we we need
to be careful on this topic regardless
of which side that you're on.
It's indisputable that the Bible uses
terms such as eternal punishment,
unquenchable fire, uh eternal fire. The
disagreement between the classicalist
and the annihilationist
is that we agree we we disagree about
what the biblical language means. Not
what exactly is said, but what it means.
But first,
let's look at Clement of Rome. Clement
knew Peter the Apostle.
This is 150 AD roughly. Quote, "If we do
the will of Christ, we shall obtain
rest. But if not, if we neglect his
commandments, nothing will rescue us
from eternal punishment." Close quote.
No. By punishment, Clement did not
believe the consequences were eternal,
but the experience wasn't.
Very plainly, Clement believed in an
eternal conscious tormentuous experience
for those who die outside of Christ.
And ironically enough, he speaks about
the neglecting of the commandments,
which Adventists claim is also a part of
this crusade that needs to be restored
that that Rome trampled. Nevertheless,
there's one.
Now, let's look at a statement from
Tatan the Assyrian.
160 AD.
He was a student of Justin Martyr. Okay?
He he was a pagan. He he moved to Rome.
I believe he became a Christian due to
to Justin Martyr's apologetics. But
notice this is from the Antonyine
fathers.
quote, "We who are now easily
susceptible to death will afterward
receive immortality with either
enjoyment or with pain."
Close quote.
John, this is long before the medieval
church. I don't care if you disagree
with him.
This is where Adventists will will say,
"But but that's not scripture." Never
said it was.
John Lomachang made a historical claim.
History disproves this notion that Rome
invented the idea of eternal conscious
torment during the medieval period which
was roughly the year you know a thousand
years 500 to the 1500s.
But thirdly
theophilos of Antioch this is in 181 AD
so still 2 century.
He he here he he's he's writing a
defense of Christianity to a guy named
Apocalypse or or Aot Lus. I don't know
how to pronounce that properly. But
nevertheless, he's defending what was
Christian orthodoxy at the time. That's
the context of his statement here. He's
defending what is at that time believed
by Christians uh universally.
Quote,
give studious attention to the prophetic
writings. He's talking about the Bible.
And they will lead you on a clearer path
to escape the eternal punishments and to
obtain the eternal good things of God.
God will examine everything and will
judge justly, granting recompense to
each according to merit. To those who
seek immortality by the patient exercise
of good works, he will give everlasting
life, joy, peace, rest, and all good
things. for the unbelievers and for the
contemptuous and for those who do who do
not submit to the truth but ascent to
iniquity sin when they've been involved
in adulteries and fornications and
homosexualities and avarice and in
lawless idolatries. There will be wrath
and indignation,
tribulation and anguish. And in the end,
such men as these will be detained in
everlasting
fire. Close quote.
Theophilus claimed that it was unc or
that it was Christian orthodoxy at the
time that God will examine everything a
person does in this life and justly
judge them. Those who seek him and seek
to do good works, he will give
everlasting life in bliss, which is
essentially the fruit of true believers
in God. Those who disobey though, who
don't come to the light, remain married
to their sin, loving their sin, a
practicer of sin, just lapping it up.
They have no conviction. They're not
warning with their sin, etc.
They don't follow the truth and will be
detained in everlasting fire as
punishment.
And notice
Theophilos like Irenaeus completely
refutes the idea that Christians just
believe human beings are innately
immortal which is that the lie that
Satan told Eve in the Garden of Eden
which is what the SDA church often tries
to posit. No, just like Irenaeus points
out in against heresies, Theophilles
believed that God is the one that grants
such and sustains the soul.
He's the only being in all of existence
that has natural immortality.
And it's that eternal being who will
then either sustain the existence of the
soul in paradise with him or in hell
apart from him in his goodness. You can
disagree with him, but history doesn't
care about your agreement or
disagreement. It's just the facts. This
is history.
None of them claimed because Christians
don't believe that God tortures people
in hell because they disagree with him
and that he's an autocrat. It's a total
caricature.
They're in hell for their sin, Mr.
Lomang, not because they simply disagree
with God.
And the issue becomes the nature of
God's holiness and that sinning against
him is an eternal offense that receives
a punishment in line with that.
And the pass a sort of even Satan's
going to be destroyed yet God will
torture humans forever. Try and measure
that up. Just silly postulating to try
and make the belief look silly.
Obviously, sir, if someone agrees with
eternal conscious torment, they think
that extends to Satan as well.
It's like learn to do an internal
critique.
When you're going to make criticisms,
understand you don't take a belief from
another system, port it into your own
system, and then say, "See, here's why
it's wrong." Because you just assume all
the stuff about your own system. It's
like when I critique Adventism,
oftentimes Adventists don't understand.
I'm doing an internal critique. I'm
assuming your own position,
showing inconsistencies in your own
system.
While you're claiming, you have the
great controversy theme, which is
supposed to be the antidote to
theological division. You've got
bulletproof theology. Every belief is
correct across the board. There's
nothing unknown like Mr. Lomang is
presenting.
But again, you're free to disagree with
the traditional position of hell. That's
not the point. The point is this
teaching was not invented by the Roman
Catholic Church during the dark ages to
warp the character of God and all the
other baloney that John uh John Lomckang
said to try and bolster Ellen White's
great controversy retelling of history.
We could look at source after source
after source of this because there are a
lot more than that.
So John, this is just another falsehood
you and other Adventists need to stop
spreading.
Add this to the just the running tab.
your card is checked in at the register
and we're just adding to your tab.
He ended there by saying, "God's not a
number of things, two of which are angry
and vengeful." Uh, Mr. Lomach,
this is where you're wrong, sir.
Again,
I I'm with you that God's not a tyrant.
He's not a maniacal cold being. But sir,
this is where Adventism shows that you
guys have a caricature of the true God.
You use his name. You claim that you
have the correct Jesus. You claim you
have the correct being of God. We're
trinitarians.
Not just in the claims Ellen White made
regarding the nature of Christ and the
nature of the Godhead, but when you guys
say stuff like this,
you show that you have a caricature.
Sir, Jesus is returning to stomp out the
grapes of wrath. The image portrayed is
that he's returning to stomp out his
enemies and cast them into outer
darkness. He doesn't have any anger and
vengeance. What are you talking about?
This idea that just love just waxes over
everything else.
We just got done reading Romans 1. The
wrath of God is actively demonstrated on
fallen sinners who shake their fist in
God's face and say, "No, I'm not going
to have you to rule over me." He says,
"All right." and gives them enough rope
to hang themselves with. They slide into
all sorts of of debased behaviors and
dis disgusting lifestyles.
Just read the Psalms, folks.
Notice Psalm 5 1-6.
Give ear to my words, O Lord.
Consider my groaning. Give attention to
the sound of my cry, my King and my God.
For to you do I pray, oh Lord, in the
morning you hear my voice. In the
morning I prepare a sacrifice for you
and watch.
For you are not a God who delights in
wickedness.
Evil may not dwell with you. The
boastful shall not stand before your
eyes. You hate all evildoers.
You destroy those who speak lies. The
Lord abhores the bloodthirsty and
deceitful man. Thus the reading of God's
holy word.
God hates all evildoers
and abhores the bloodthirsty and
deceitful man
which Mr. Lomang God hates the practices
that take place in Adventist affiliated
hospitals where they shed the blood of
unborn children.
He doesn't just hate sin but love the
sinner. This is one of these modern-day,
you know, sayings that people hear and
just think, "Oh, yeah, the Bible doesn't
say that."
No, he hates the evildoer.
This doesn't sound like the character of
the avenous God. Again, in Psalm Psalm
11-6,
the Lord is in his holy temple. The
Lord's throne is in heaven. His eyes
see, his eyelids test the children of
man. The Lord tests the righteous, but
his soul hates the wicked, and the one
who loves violence.
Let him rain coals on the wicked. Fire
and sulfur and a scorching wind shall be
the portion of their cup. Thus, the
reading of God's holy word.
God hates the wicked and the one that
loves violence, which is why he's
eventually going to pour his wrath out
on them.
The idea that the SDA church, their idea
of God is a caricature.
His love just completely overshadows
everything else.
This is why their rejection of the
doctrine of divine simplicity that they
try and attribute to aristoilian
philosophy. It leads them to error. They
don't understand that God is who he is.
He's loving, kind, merciful, just,
angry, vengeful, holy, etc. It's not
like 50% love, 10% just, and so on.
Adventists love to claim Christians have
a warped view of the character of God.
Yet, ironically,
they not only have a false god, but
claim the character of the true God to
be something it's not. It's all love and
that's it.
But also, Mr. came Protestants never
agreed with your guys' view of the
nature of man
that he has no immaterial aspect of his
being or in annihilationism.
The SDA church and her apologists love
to to to try and appeal to Martin Luther
here, but Luther evolved on his position
over time due to the biblical text.
I always chuckle when I when they say
this because Rome loves to point to that
same thing, but they do it to claim it
shows that Luther didn't actually know
what he believed and he was just a
problematic schismatic.
The title of your presentation, sir, is
Protestantism has been hijacked.
Yet all you've demonstrated is that you
guys are the ones doing the hijacking
because first generation classical
Protestants never agreed with you guys
on any of these points. And as we saw in
part one, you guys are in line with the
Anabaptists, the radical reformers,
not the Protestant reformers.
And Daniel 8:12 talks about how Rome
distorted the truth of God's word during
the dark ages. And the Bible says in
Romans 8 and verse 12, I mean Daniel 8
and verse 12, because of transgression,
an army was given over to the little
horn, that is the papacy, to oppose the
daily sacrifice, and he cast truth down
to the ground. He did all this and
prospered. He prospered. He very well
did prosper. He prospered for a certain
period of time. And then God said,
"Enough is enough." God gave Rome 1,260
years to do all their exploits. And then
God stepped in. And God began the
Protestant Reformation. And you see,
Protestantism was intended to restore
the character of God by guiding people
back to what? To the undiluted truth of
God's word. But something went wrong.
Which brings me to
Yet again, more great controversy
filtering of history as well as just
outright fiction.
Adventists over the decades have tried
all sorts of twisting and reimagining of
this paricopy of scripture to try and
make it work. Because as we've looked at
many times,
all of 7th Day Adventism hinges on
Daniel 8:14, of which verse 12 is
connected.
video on Monday is on this specific
topic.
It is important to realize folks
former Adventists, current Adventists,
Christian,
the 19th century understanding of this
passage is not the same as the 20th,
which isn't the same as the 21st.
Desmond Ford actually documents this
down really well in his book
uh uh Daniel 8:14 and and the
investigative judgment,
but they've tried to hide behind present
truth as an excuse as to why they've
shifted and twisted on what's going on
in these verses.
But notice, he only cited verse 12
because when it's looked at
contextually, it poses all sorts of
problems for them.
Look, Daniel 8 9-14.
Out of one of them came a little horn,
which grew exceedingly great toward the
south, toward the east, and toward the
glorious land. It grew great even to the
host of heaven. And some of the host,
and some of the stars it threw down to
the ground, and trampled on them. It
became great, even as great as the
prince of the host. and the regular
burnt offering was taken away from it,
and the place of his sanctuary was
overthrown. And a host will be given
over to it together with the regular
burnt offering because of transgression.
And it will throw truth to the ground,
and it will act and prosper. Then I
heard a holy one speaking, and another
holy one said to the one who spoke, "For
how long is the vision concerning the
regular burnt offering, the
transgression that makes desolate, and
the giving over of the sanctuary, and
host to be trampled underfoot,
and he said to me, for 2300 evening and
more evenings and mornings, then the
sanctuary shall be restored to its
rightful state." And thus the reading of
God's holy word.
So a little horn rises up, grows
exceedingly great. This wicked little
horn then throws some of the stars down
and tramples them. In this
transgression, the regular service of
the sanctuary was halted, casting truth
to the ground, which gave the appearance
that the wicked the the wicked little
horn was prospering.
Daniel then hears an angel ask another
angel because he's in vision. How long
will this wicked figure do this?
That gives an indicator as to what the
2300 evenings and mornings is in
reference to. It's about a wicked figure
doing wicked things. How long? The
answer is then given in verse 14. For
2300 evenings and mornings, not days
Adventists, evenings and mornings. and
then the sanctuary will be restored to
its rightful place.
One doesn't even have to get into all
the symbols and who exactly they
represent to trounce the SDA theory.
This is why no one, including all the
previous historicists before the SDA
church, ever arrived at this a faulty
conclusion.
The 2300 evenings and mornings pertain
to a wicked figure, not a righteous one.
It's a time frame for how long this
wicked figure is going to do wicked
things. and then stop.
It is not a time frame for when
something will begin.
something will start. That after 2,300
days, something's going to start. No,
the sanctuary will be restored to how it
was prior to this wicked action taking
place.
Well, this has posed all sorts of
problems for the SDA church because
contextually again the 2300 evenings and
mornings has to do with a wicked figure,
not a righteous one. But because they've
inserted Jesus into the mix by claiming
it's about when he will begin cleansing
the heavenly sanctuary, they have to
claim that Jesus desecrated the heavenly
sanctuary and that was done by him
taking in sin laden blood into heaven.
And they've s they they've since tried
to pivot off this, by the way, because
of the obvious problems.
They claim the truth that was cast down
was the gospel, specifically the message
about the investigative judgment in
Christ's high priestly work and the
sanctuary, which the SDA church
supposedly recovered.
So when it says then the sanctuary will
be restored to its rightful place, they
think it means then the SDA teaching of
the sanctuary is going to be recognized
and restored. Except no,
as we've seen multiple times, they claim
it's a present truth message given to a
specific people at the end of time. No
one before them had that message of
which the sanctuary doctrine is
included.
Yet at the same time, it was supposedly
restored.
That would mean it had to have been
around before 1844, fell away, but then
came back.
Either way, Mr. Lomang, none of what you
guys assert about this verse is a plain
thus sayeth the Lord.
We heard a lot of SDA assertions about
the text, but it doesn't plainly say
what you stated.
Furthermore,
you don't think the papacy has prospered
since 1844?
It's like pro prospering only included
pillaging and doineering, I guess.
Nevertheless, he said the 1260 years
brought us to the Protestant
Reformation. Well, hold up now. Hold up
now.
It's supposed to be the 1260 years of
papal persecution. Yet, it's 2300
evenings and mornings that this
prosperity in Daniel would happen.
1260 doesn't get you guys to where you
need to be on the timeline. So
regardless of what and who one thinks
all the symbols represent, it can still
be deduced through logic, reason,
and looking at the text contextually to
see that your guys's interpretation is
val is invalid.
The Protestant reformers did not agree
with you all on the investigative
judgment in the sanctuary.
You guys love appealing to them,
claiming that they were all
historicists,
which makes you guys heirs of them
supposedly. Yet none of them understood
this passage the way that you guys do.
And as a passing note, no, all of the
reformers Adventists were not
historicists.
Hugo Grocious,
Jeene Lller,
partial predis.
So if you hear an Adventist emphatically
tell you that all of the reformers were
historicists to try and validate their
theories, politely explain to them that
no, this is not true.
But he said the purpose of the
Protestant Reformation was to restore
the character of God.
Mr. Lomang,
in part one, we looked at a number of
the key areas that the reformers were
seeking to reform the church. You have
inserted a false definition
of what it means to be Protestant and
then have built your entire foundation
on that.
But now you've inserted more falsehoods
into the mix. Again, we get more Ellen
White being paraphr being paraphrased
not cited.
The Great Controversy 1888 edition page
297.
quote,
"The Protestant churches of America and
those of Europe as well, so highly
favored in receiving the blessings of
the Reformation, failed to press forward
in the path of reform,
failed to press forward in the path of
reform.
Though a few faithful men arose from
time to time to proclaim new truth
and expose long cherished error, the
majority like the Jews in Christ's day.
Oh, we get this parallel again. Or the
papist in the time of Luther were
content to believe as their fathers had
believed and to live as they had lived.
Therefore, religion again degenerated
into formalism
and errors and superstitions which would
have been cast aside had the church
continued to walk in the light of God's
word were retained and cherished.
Thus, the spirit inspired by the
reformation gradually died out until
there was almost as great a need of
reform in the Protestant churches as in
the Roman church in the time of Luther.
There was the same worldliness and
spiritual stuper, a similar reverence
for the opinions of man and substitution
of human theories for the teaching of
God's word. Close quote.
This is the supposed
that happened to the pro to
Protestantism that Mr. Lomachang is
referring to. Yet the things that he
claims Protestants fell into leading to
apostasy, they've always believed like
Sunday being the Christian Sabbath, the
state of the dead, the nature of man,
etc.
The Protestant reformers all embraced
the things Ellen White claims are just
traditions leading to them being
denigrated into formalism and superi
superstitions.
This is Anabaptist thinking, not
Protestant thinking. Oh, I just didn't
reform far enough. That's what the
Anabaptist said. To where you've
reformed so far, you look nothing like
the church.
This is the thing that's so funny about
all this is like they they refuse to
continue accepting new light. Except to
accept seventh day Adventism is
literally to accept a different view on
like literally everything. It's not just
like, oh, Adventism just has the seventh
day Sabbath. That's just the thing
they're or the nature of man and that's
what they're trying to to to like get
everybody on board with. No, it's a
whole system.
The whole system of Protestant belief
falls apart. The whole Catholic faith
meaning universal. Yes, Adventist.
Catholic is not a bad word. I don't mean
Roman Catholic. I mean the universal
Christian faith.
You have to abandon all of that to
accept Adventism. There's literally not
a single point of it that's on board
because again it's all filtered through
the great controversy theme. Even if you
point to things like, oh well what they
believe about baptism, everyone, you
know, there's other people out there
that believe in like a baptismal
regeneration view. No, it's not just
that. That's not the unique aspect.
Every point of Adventist theology that
they want to point to to say, well, this
isn't really unique to us. Like they'll
say the seventh day Sabbath. They'll try
and say, "Well, we know that the the
investigative judgment is the only novel
doctrine to us." Well, no. Even your
belief about the seventh day Sabbath has
novel components. The other seventh day
Sabotarian groups don't believe it's the
seal of God, the final dividing line,
etc. So, even that teaching gets
filtered through the great controversy
theme leading to all these novel beliefs
about it.
But they love the shtick just like the
Anabaptist and radical reformers did.
The Protestant reformers didn't go far
enough. Yet again, the SDA church looks
absolutely nothing like the Protestant
reformers.
So the SDA church has oppos has
apparently reformed so much that they
look nothing like actual Protestantism.
Yet they're the true last remaining
bastion of Protestantism in the world.
No, dude.
Attack apostate
Protestantism. Now let me just say that
again and give some qualifying to that.
Why apostate? The truth of God's word
develops the truth of God. The truth of
every doctrine you teach reflects the
truth about who Jesus is. Anytime you
see that he is not satisfied and burns
sinners forever, he is seen as worse
than Hitler or any kind of tyrant that
has ever walked the earth. But that is
not who God is. That is not who Jesus
Christ is. But when aposta when
Protestantism turned away from the
truth, they were now in apostasy just
like Ahab in the Old Testament. And they
began through their teachings to
misrepresent
the character of God. Because you know
when you say you know God from that
point on society is going to form their
opinion about God based on what they
hear and what they see revealed through
your preaching and through the way that
you live. And that is why when a teacher
or a preacher says they know God, the
Bible says if they say they know me,
here's the measurement as to whether or
not they are telling you the truth. 1
John 2 and verse4. Let us allow the
Bible to speak for itself. The Bible
says, "He who says, "I know him and does
not keep his commandments is a liar and
the truth is not in him." Now, it's
amazing that that goes right back to
what Elijah said to Ahab. You are the
one that has forsaken the commandments
of God. You're the one that's causing
trouble. You notice what Ahab is guilty
of is what the Apostle John is saying
many will be guilty of in the end times.
They'll say they know God like Ahab
said, but they will refuse to keep the
commandments of God. And the word of God
says, "He who says he knows me but
doesn't keep my commandments, watch out,
because the truth is not in him." You
can't trust what he says because he
doesn't stand by the very indicator
of his love for me. If you love me, keep
my commandments. Oh, I love you, Lord,
but not that much. The Lord says, don't
trust him because he will not tell you
the truth. Because the measurement of
truth, he refuses to stand by. You see
friends, the ten commandments of God's
word was permanently and indelibly
connected to rightly representing the
character of God.
Notice what Jesus said. John 17 and
verse three. He says this, "And this is
eternal life
that they may know you, the only true
God and Jesus Christ whom you sent." In
other words, when I know Jesus Christ,
then I have eternal life. But how do I
know? How do you know that I that I know
Jesus Christ? He says, "If you say I
know him, if he says he knows me and
does not keep his commandments, he
really doesn't know me and eternal life
is not something that abides on him."
That's why today we've got to be very
careful because we live in an
environment today where religion is
popular.
Politicians talk about religion.
Presidents talk about religion. World
leaders use religion to manipulate the
society. What do you believe? Are you a
Christian leader? And Christianity has
never been the foundation by which a
political agenda is decided.
Christian values are intended to shape
the life of the individual. But Christ
never enforced Christ never imposed his
beliefs on someone who did not love him.
So when politicians use Christianity to
say, "Well, if he's not a Christian,
he's not a valuable or reliable leader."
That's not what the Bible teaches
because Jesus says, "Render to Caesar
what's his into God what what is his."
Christianity is intend to transform the
life, not to be used as a tool of
manipulation for any kind of political
expediency.
All right. So, Satan's third attack,
apostate Protestantism.
So the first attack on God's character
supposedly came from Satan in heaven
before the earth was even created. The
second was supposedly the Roman Catholic
Church during the dark ages inventing
doctrines like eternal conscious torment
which we saw. No, that that wasn't
invented out of thin air in the the dark
ages or in the dark ages period.
Now we get Satan's last and final grand
attack on God.
Apostate Protestantism.
Ah,
Mr. Lomang, again, you are either
horribly ignorant or knowingly dishonest
because the things you claim about
Protestants that we believe that makes
them that makes us apostate, we've
always believed.
I mean, we even got the worst than
Hitler.
emotional manipulation tactic. Like,
come on, dude. What a joke. All that
does is show that you have a very warped
view of the holiness of God and why
sinning against such a being is
deserving of such anguish.
And saying such a thing makes me wonder
if you ever if you've ever come under
the crushing weight and agony of your
sin,
recognizing that you are deserving of
such punishment for your sin, sir.
You understand who you sinned against?
The fact that you would think, "Oh,
well, it just you don't understand sin,
sir. The severity of sin if you say
something like this. Yes, you're
deserving of that. You're deserving to
be in agony apart from God's goodness,
mercy, and joy. That's why hell is
terrible.
Not because God is some maniacal cold
whatever, but it's that your sin is
deserving of such.
Have you ever come under the crushing
weight of that? Seriously?
Because when you when you try and do the
worse than Hitlerick, you evidence that
you have a very low view of the holiness
of God. something I hardly ever heard
about in Adventism
other than some way to segue into
focusing on you, the individual.
And he says all of this as if that's the
view of God that Protestants have.
We think he's some maniacal,
bloodthirsty tyrant. Without this straw
man, this part of their narrative
completely breaks down.
It shows, like we've seen in countless
other areas,
they don't even know what they're
criticizing.
Our view of hell isn't informed by God
being a tyrannical autocrat. It's based
on phrases such as, "They are tormented
day and night, forever and ever, and
will have no rest day or night."
as well as understanding the holiness of
God, the severity of which that offense
has been made, who it's being made
against, etc.
Yet, you guys don't ever mention this.
You do the worse than Hitler appeal, the
appeal to emotion fallacy, to try and
paint the picture that you guys have
restored some loving character of God
while everyone else is evangelizing and
worshiping an evil tyrant who was
concocted during the dark ages.
I'm just I'm so tired of this particular
lie. It's like I remember being taught
this as a kid, you know, these sorts of
things like, well, they have this view
of God that it just
so false, man. It's so false. It's like
knowing the goodness of God, the mercy
of God, like like we worship some
maniacal
just just crazy. Just silliness.
Especially considering the Adventist God
might be one of the worst idols ever
concocted.
Like dude, even the pagans idols are not
like the Adventist idol.
The Adventist God at any given second,
he might damn you because sinless
perfection is required to appease him
because his character has to be
vindicated.
So you have to keep the law perfectly to
help him out and get him off the hook
from the devil.
So he sent Jesus to make it possible for
man to meet the requirements and give
you an upgrade in your hardware such
that you can now start on the path
towards sinlessness and vindicate him.
But along the way, if you mess up at any
point, you're back under condemnation.
And you have to make sure to confess
that sin to Jesus so he can deal with it
in the investigative judgment.
Otherwise, Satan's going to be able to
bring up a charge against you in the the
coming courtroom scene,
and Jesus won't be able to show that
you're a justly savable individual, that
he's that he's righteous and just in
saving you because you haven't arrived
to the point of silencing Satan's
accusation.
The Adventist God is a projection of
Ellen White's warped mind.
So, don't give me that. Don't don't give
me that. this idea that the Adventist
God is just you're restoring. No, you're
not. You're restoring and resurrecting.
You you you've resurrected up and and
laid up an idol. An idol. Don't tell me
that Christians worship a a maniacal
god.
He said Protestants went apostate when
they turned from the truth just like
Ahab in the Old Testament. Yet again,
Mr. Lomang for the hundth time we get
more Ellen White being confused for a
plain thus sayeth the Lord.
If at this point folks it isn't obvious
those that have been riding with us for
a long time
if if it's not obvious at this point
how Ellen White is seen as no different
than scripture when it comes to by the
book Adventism.
I don't know what's going to do it for
you. I I'm not I don't care about the
liberal the the the the whatever. No,
this is by the book Adventism. I have
enough respect for John Lomccang,
Clifford Goldstein, Doug Bachelor,
Steven Bore, Dwayne Lemon, these
individuals that recognize, no, this is
what the system teaches. It's not a
grabback. It's not, well, I'm an
Adventist, but I don't. No, no, you're
not. Then you don't understand the
system to that you adhere to. You're
just trying to do a buffet style. It
doesn't work that way. And these people
like John Loccane understand that, which
is why they're teaching what they're
claiming.
What truth did Protestants supposedly
turn from and become apostate?
Oh, notice Ellen G. White, great
controversy, 1888 edition. This is
starting from page uh 379 to 380. It's a
little long, so bear with me, folks. But
this is important. Okay.
She writes, "Remember what did
Protestants supposedly turn from and
become apostate?"
Because Mr. Lomachang didn't go into all
the details about what's being shieldled
out here. This is all the details or at
least some of them because there's more
things than than just what she covers
here. a quote.
Such were the blessed results
experienced by those who accepted the
advent message.
This is the original Millerite movement
before 7th day Adventism is even born.
Okay?
They came from different denominations
and their denominational barriers were
hurled to the ground. Conflicting creeds
were shivered to Adams. The unscriptural
hope of a temporal millennium was
abandoned. False views of the second
advent were corrected. Pride and
conformity to the world were swept away.
Wrongs were made right. Hearts were
united in the sweetest fellowship. And
love and joy reigned supreme.
If this doctrine did this for a few who
did receive it, it would have done the
same for all if all had received it.
So here's the foundation, the launching
pad. Look what it did for the
Millerites.
Had those other pagans, Christians,
accepted this, it would have done the
same for them. That's what she's getting
at here.
But the churches generally did not
accept the warning.
Their ministers, who as watchmen unto
the house of Israel, should have been
the first to discern the tokens of
Jesus's coming, had failed to learn the
truth, either from the testimony of the
prophets or from the signs of the times.
As worldly hopes and ambitions filled
the heart, love for God and faith in his
word had grown cold. And when the Advent
doctrine was presented, it only aroused
their prejudice and unbelief.
The fact that the message was to a great
extent preached by laymen was urged as
an argument against it.
As of old, the plain testimony of God's
word was met with the inquiry, have any
of the rulers or of the Pharisees
believed?
and finding how difficult a task it was
to refute the arguments drawn from the
prophetic periods. Many discouraged the
study of the prophecies,
teaching that the prophetic books were
sealed and were not to be understood.
Multitudes trusting implicitly in their
p or to their pastors refused to listen
to the warning and others though
convinced of the truth dared not confess
it lest they should be put out of the
synagogue.
The message which God had sent for the
testing and purification of the church
revealed all too surely how great was
the number who had set their affections
on this world rather than upon Christ.
The ties which bound them to earth were
stronger than the attractions
heavenward. They chose to listen to the
voice of worldly wisdom and turned away
from the heart uh searching message of
truth.
In refusing the warning of the first
angel,
they rejected the means which heaven had
provided for their restoration.
They spurned the ca the gracious
messenger that would have corrected the
evils which separated from them from
God.
They spurned the grac the gracious
messenger that would have corrected the
evils which separated them from God. And
with greater eagerness they turned to
seek the friendship of the world. Here
was the cause of that fearful condition
of worldliness, backsliding and
spiritual death which existed in the
churches in 1844.
Close quote.
Ah. So now we see how Protestants went
into apostasy supposedly. Let's break
this down. So in the the days of
Millerism, various people from various
denominations came together by accepting
Miller's esquetology which included the
belief in the imminent
imminent return of Christ. not the
belief in a physical literal second
coming altogether, which they love to
try and claim, as we saw uh last week.
It also included premillennialism and
the belief in a literal 1,000-year
millennial reign over and against a
symbolic understanding of the millennium
which has historically been believed to
be representative of a per of the period
from the cross to the second coming with
Christ ruling and reigning from heaven
with all authority while all of his
enemies are being made his foottool.
But William Miller, an uneducated farmer
who supposedly uh uh was supposedly
raised up by God to correct these
esqueological errors with his King James
Bible and a concordance. Yes, those were
his tools.
She then points out that because of this
lack of qualifications, people rightly
didn't take him seriously.
to which her response is, this is the
same argument the religious leaders made
in the days of Jesus.
One of her favorite analogies like we
saw earlier.
This is also why modern-day SDAism will
often poo poo on theological training,
except of course if you're if you're
being trained in SDA institutions.
Remember, rules for thee, not for we.
But we also see one of their favorite
claims that many modern SDAs will make
and have inherited and they don't even
realize it.
The claim that Christians in the pioneer
days in SDA pioneers day claimed the
books of prophecy in the Bible are
closed off in a mystery and no one's
actually able to understand them.
But not the Adventists,
they're prophecy experts. They've
really, really studied the Bible more
than anyone else, which is why God
showed them extra light and favor and
opened up these secret closed books.
Except no, this is ludicrous.
Like I said, as can be seen by the
countless commentaries,
systematic theologies
that all existed during the time and
before
the SDA church was even born.
But they love to claim this, which is
why they think their movement was raised
up as a prophetic voice to show the
truth about prophecy with the rest of
the Christian world. uh uh uh who thinks
that it's all closed off and mysterious
and no one actually knows when the fact
is no. Christian theologians have
recognized that esquetology is an
advanced topic with many moving parts
and yes unknowns.
The silly idea that they've cracked
every sign, symbol, and seal because
they have some prophet is laughable,
especially considering all of their
changing and reinterpreting of say
Daniel 8:14
from the 19th century to now. But then
they'll just try and say, "Oh, no,
present truth." Oh, how convenient,
right? Oh, present truth. It was present
truth in 1849 to believe the time of
trouble was going to come on that
generation. It didn't. Oh, but present
truth changed.
But notice, she also claimed that
Miller's message was a testing message
sent by God as a purification method of
the church. So when people rightly
rejected their fanaticism and false date
setting, they failed the test and God
gave them up.
This was supposedly the means that God
had sent to restore them from
catastrophic error, but they spurned the
council of God's humble servant, William
Miller, in this case. And in doing so,
they were separated from God. So, if you
don't believe in imminency,
you're rejecting a heavenscent warning
provided for your restoration. Get that?
If you don't believe in the imminent
return, you're separated from God.
It's just it's just crazy, man. This
idea that it's just like everyone's in
error until they accepted the imminent
return. If you don't believe the
imminent return, you're lost. That's a
false belief. So, you have a false god.
It's just
mercy, man. It could be today. It could
be 500 years from now. Live in light of
that regardless. this idea that that's
unique to Adventism. It it's just study
this this the the 16th 17th centuries
man leading up to that time period and
you'll see why they they were saying
these just ridiculous things.
This is Ellen White's retelling of
history though which is supposed to be
inspired and infallible.
So Protestants are apostate because
we're not Seventh Day Adventists.
That's essentially because it didn't end
with Millerism. You have to go along
with all of the craziness of the shut
door period, the fiasco of the great
disappointment, and everything else that
they've contrived leading to the present
day. The Miller chart was a a test. The
first angel's message, the message of
Millerism, that was a test. Uh the
Sabbath is a test.
the the the first angel's message now
turning into the eventually the
investigative judgment in the sanctuary.
That was a test. All of this stuff is
supposedly a test from God that if you
reject it as ridiculous, God has
rejected you.
They'll use all sorts of excuses to try
and justify this. They'll say, "I I just
had a guy this past week, one of their
favorite ones. Revelation 10 even
predicted Millerism in the great
disappointment, bro.
Literally all of scripture is read with
them in focus.
Nars Jesus as Chris Roseboro has called
it.
You read the Bible just it's all about
you. You you you just read yourself
everywhere into the Bible. First Kings
18, Ezekiel, Daniel, Revelation, on and
on and on. They're the central figures
of scripture. The whole world is going
to be at enmity with EV 7th Day
Adventist
Adventist. Seriously, and I don't say
this as an insult. I say this with a
heavy heart. I pity you. I pity you.
I've been there. That's why.
But there you go. Mr. Lomachang, spare
us the euphemisms and platitudes.
You are simply regurgitating Ellen White
and her historical revisionism to claim
that because we aren't Seventh Day
Adventists and didn't go along with the
hysteria of all the crazy hysteria of
19th century America, we were rejected
by God. Yeah. Okay.
He cited First John 2:4. Did you catch
it? Did you catch it?
Folks, I'm gonna be doing a video on
this eventually.
I've mentioned it I don't know how many
times on the platform. Word association
fallacy. We're going to create I'm going
to create some sort of alarm that we can
sound off every time we detect this so
you can start to see it. Yes. Again, we
heard the classic. If the word
commandment is used, it means ten
commandments, just not in Hebrews 7:18.
and we're the only ones who go to church
on Saturday, which is what the fourth
commandment is. So therefore, we're the
commandment keeping church. That's the
messaging here. Not just that, but then
he tries
he he tries tying it to Ahab in First
Kings.
Like, oh brother, Mr. Lomang, John tells
you what he means here in the very next
chapter.
in the very next chapter. Sir,
this is a classic one, folks. Arm your
arsenal with this,
arm your arsenal with this. Every time
the word commandments used, it doesn't
mean ten commandments automatically. And
recognizing that does not mean that you
hate the ten commandments or that you
think, oh, the ten commandments have no
use. Again, that's the false dilemma
fallacy. Don't just use another fallacy.
Recognizing this has nothing to do with
whether the Ten Commandments are still
valid or not. It has to do with the fact
that that's not what John's talking
about here. Notice
1 John 3:1 19- 24.
John is talking about the call to love
one another. He's talking about the
hallmark signs of how you can know
somebody's a Christian. He's refuting
Gnostic heresy, ironically,
specifically regarding the idea of
certain Gnostic groups. folks believed
that Jesus was a holographic projection
of light from heaven because they
believed the physical universally across
the gnostic groups they believed that
physical matter was evil.
So there was there were groups of people
early on in the church trying to when
Christologology was being hammered out
dealing with heresies like the SDA
churches resurrected.
They were claiming Jesus wasn't actually
a man. He wasn't truly human
which led to the church nailing down no
this is what the truth is on this.
That's what John is predominantly
dealing with at the toward toward the
beginning which is why he talks about
the person the the person that rejects
that Christ came in the flesh true human
flesh is antichrist etc. But he's giving
hallmarks for how you can know somebody
who claims to be a Christian is a
Christian. One of the hallmarks here is
love for the body. If you don't love the
Christian church, if you're not involved
in the Christian church, if you're not
serving the Christian church, you don't
love Christ's body. There's no such
thing as a rogue Christian. I'm sorry.
You need to be attached to First John
was written to a local body of corporate
gathered believers. Okay, that's what
he's getting at here. Notice what it
says.
By this we shall know that we are of the
truth. Mr. Lomang earlier you said don't
believe that person they're not keeping
the ten commandments so therefore you
know don't trust them they don't
actually love God they may say that but
they don't really
this is how we are to know of we that we
are of the truth
and reassure our heart before him
for whenever our heart condemns us God
is greater than our heart and he knows
everything beloved if our heart does not
condemn us We have confidence before
God. Ah, something deeper than the Ten
Commandments. Mr. Lomck,
people's hearts can convict them over
things that the Ten Commandments don't
even mention.
Yes, the Ten Commandments are not an
exhaustive summation of morality.
Beloved, if our heart does not condemn
us, we have confidence before God. And
whatever we ask, we receive from him
because we keep his commandments and do
what pleases him. And this is his
commandment
that we believe in the name of his son
Jesus Christ and love one another just
as he has commanded us. Whoever keeps
his commandments, believing on the Lord
Jesus, loving the body,
abides in God and God in him. And by
this we know that he abides in us by the
spirit whom he has given us.
Ah, spirit, seal, down payment, born
again. Thus, the reading of God's holy
word.
Sir, the commandments in focus are to
believe on the Lord Jesus Christ and
love one another. These are the
hallmarks of a true Christian. If you
hate your brother, you don't love God.
If you don't believe on the Lord Jesus
Christ, you don't love God, the true
Christ. Not the Gnostic Jesus who wasn't
truly human. Not the Adventist Jesus who
was insert all the the things that that
the Adventist Jesus is not the true
Jesus on or the Mormon Jesus or the
Jehovah's Witness Jesus etc.
If you don't have the true Christ, you
don't love God. It doesn't matter that
you go to church on Saturday. It's
irrelevant. You have a false God.
The fact that you guys will cite these
little pieces of of scripture to your
own condemnation. We care about you,
sir.
Let me make myself clear.
I'm not just trying to to rag on you. We
care about you, sir. I like Adventists.
They're great people.
This isn't me saying Adventists are
terrible people.
It's just that this is not a plain, thus
sayeth the Lord.
What I just read is a plain, thus sayeth
the Lord. the commandments in view just
like in John 14
is to love one another. It's not talking
about the ten commandments and that
doesn't mean the ten commandments don't
still have a use in the Christian life.
Are there some groups of people out
there that disagree with that? Yes.
That's not Protestants. Your talk is
about apostate Protestantism.
It's that we don't believe those things
maintain our righteous standing before
God. You guys have a worksbased system.
Ironically, Mr. Lomachang has mentioned
John 14:15. If you love me, keep my
commandments twice in his in this talk
just in this and in the last part.
In John 13, he speaks of the commandment
to love one another in Christ's physical
absence. The apostles are disheartened
in the discussion
and they're they're they're wondering
how they're going to function as his
disciples in the world if he's going
back to the father.
Well, he says, "You'll be known as my
disciples in the world by your love for
one another." This is the same John
and explains that if you love Christ,
you'll also love one another as he said
to do.
And again, Adventists will be quick to
say that if you point this out, this
means you're downplaying the Ten
Commandments,
which is just responding to one logical
fallacy with another. It's a false
dilemma fallacy to claim it's either you
believe what we do about the
commandments or you think people should
just disregard them entirely
when no, it's just a simple fact. These
paricopies are not talking about the Ten
Commandments. And recognizing that has
no bearing on whether or not you believe
the Ten Commandments have a use in the
Christian life. We looked at this myth
and silenced it in part one.
But even if we were talking about the
Ten Commandments, even if we were, Mr.
Lomachang, you guys don't keep the Ten
Commandments.
We looked at that last time, too. False
God. On that alone, you violate all all
four of the first commandments
which are all God-facing.
You yourself have violated the ninth
commandment multiple times in this talk
bearing false witness about Christians.
So I guess we should watch out for you
all. Like you said, watch out.
You guys don't stand by the only
indicator of love for God.
Notice he says they'll say they know God
and love God, but because they don't
keep his commandments, aka they don't
believe like we do about the fourth
commandment, so therefore they aren't
really following God.
We don't actually love God because we
don't agree with you.
Just
again, the target in the sites is
Christians, folks.
This guy is giving a talk claiming to be
a Christian, claiming all the other
so-called Christians out there are
apostates.
It's not that that's not they they think
oftentimes too. This is what Christians
preach from the pulpits.
Christians, that's who's in their
sights. Don't give me this nonsense.
SDAs in the comments.
Why are you picking on one group? Why?
No, we're not buying it. It's over. It's
over. The game is over. Okay.
You picked this fight. You're an attack.
Your movement is an attack on the
Christian church. I love the body of
Christ. That's why this platform exists.
Those old tactics of trying to silence
people to try and position it as
projection or a gaslighting where you
try and make the individual pointing out
the error the one that's in in the
wrong. No, you guys started this. Just
even study the early days like they try
to demonize canrite. Just read other
sources during that day. The SDAs of
that time were a nuisance. They went
around disturbing the peace. They were
condemning everyone. But now that time
has gone on, they're like, "Oh man, we
have to reposition ourselves." Just like
the Mormons, just like Jehovah's
Witnesses. They always have to pivot
when things don't go as anticipated.
But the target in the sights is not the
lost, not Muslims, not secularists, not
Buddhists, not Hindus, Christians.
I highlight this in hopes that it will
wake some people up. This organization's
biggest enemy is you.
You're supposedly under the influence of
Satan as his stooges to eventually
persecute the humble instruments of God,
the Seventh Day Adventist.
John, spare us the line that you guys
are some ardent defenders of the Ten
Commandments. You guys lie about
Christians constantly and it makes me
sick.
And I do love the body like First John
is actually talking about as the
commandment in view. And it makes me
sick how this organization
doles out talks like these to who knows
even how many people, tens of thousands,
hundreds of thousands, potentially
millions of people,
spreading lies and slander about the
body of Christ.
Your movement is definitionally an
accuser of the brethren, a tool of
Satan.
You all are guilty of spreading a false
gospel, a false god, the writings of a
false prophet.
That violates uh the third commandment.
By the way,
people are in the right to warn against
you guys and point this out. I don't
care if you guys try and spin it as
evidence that you're persecuted to play
the victim complex card. People need
warned about Adventist theology. Full
stop.
No amount of twisting scripture to try
and make it fit with what you're you're
selling changes that. No appeals to
emotion. I mean, people try everything,
dude. They they try everything other
than dealing with the the facts. Truth
does not care about your feelings. It
doesn't care about your emotions. It's
not to say those things do not have a
place, but when it comes to objectivity,
folks, deal with the problems.
Don't shoot the messenger. Don't use ad
homonym, etc.
SDAs are not victims. No one has
persecuted them. The jig is up. It's
time to face the music. Except that you
guys were wrong. You aren't the apple of
God's eye. 1844 was a farce. Nothing
happened aside from the birth of a of a
parasitic organization that exists to
attack the Christian church.
He cited Jesus's high high priestly
prayer in John 17.
Mr. Lom King. This is the problem with
ignoring context and just connecting
verses together willy-nilly because they
use the same words. This is called word
association fallacy.
And it's primarily built on your faulty
claim that 1 John 2, 1 John 2 3-4. You
can remember it by 1 2 3 4. That's how I
remember this set of verses. Now, by
this we know that we know him. if we
keep his commandments. He who says I
know him does not keep his commandments
is a liar and the truth is not in it.
But it's built this whole claim is built
primarily on your faulty claim that 1
John 2:4 is talking about the ten
commandments which again even if it were
you guys are disqualified.
He says the comm the the commandments
that's being referred to
are believing on the Lord Jesus and love
for his bride, the church. This fits
handin glove with what Jesus says in his
high priestly prayer because the same
John tells us in his first epistle that
if we don't have the son, we don't have
the father.
In his high priestly prayer, we see that
Jesus spelled out that same thing just
worded differently.
Furthermore, this verse actually buries
one of your guys' other common lies,
which is that Christians believe all
human beings are by nature immortal,
which is supposedly believing the lie of
Satan and Eden, the first lie, etc. No,
in actuality, this verse shows eternal
life is not merely indefinite existence.
It's knowing the one true God, which
obviously not all people do. So even if
we did affirm what you guys claim, we
don't. This verse silences that
assertion. He talked about Christians
and politicians. Dude, if you think
American government is filled with
Christian politicians
and they're saying if a per if a person
isn't a Christian, then they aren't a
reliable leader, then you are without a
doubt living in an alternate reality. I
I mean, it's almost hard to even
comprehend how someone could think such
a thing in 2023 America,
but also
like we looked at in part one, this was
Anabaptist thinking to the core, not
Protestant.
The Anabaptists had this hyper
separation of church and state view, not
the magisterial reformers,
which is almost hilarious regarding
Adventism, seeing that they're
headquartered in Washington DC and have
all sorts of their members in government
seeking to influence in favor of
Adventism.
Jesus saying, "Render unto Caesar what
is Caesars's," has nothing to do with
Christians not being involved involved
in the culture and needing to to to set
uh their fundamental foundational
beliefs of their worldview to the side
to adopt some sort of like daily
temporary on the job worldview of the
pagans, but only while doing your
vocation. Then when you get home, you
can embrace that Christian worldview
again. Tell that to David, Solomon,
Joseph.
It's that sort of mindset that's gotten
us into the current mess that we're in.
This used to be a halfway decent nation.
Not perfect,
but my goodness, man. It's like the the
what is it? What do you think this is,
Mr. Lom King? Like 1940,
1960. It's like, shoot, even in 1940,
they had terrible things that needed
remedied.
But this shows that you guys don't
really think that Joe Biden, Xihinping,
Emanuel Mcronone, etc. are all actually
accountable to Jesus who's actually
ruling and reigning over all of heaven
and earth right now. They're all subject
to King Jesus. He is who is in charge.
No, the political sphere is not a
handsoff domain for him.
Folks, do not forget this. Then we're
going to then we're going to get into
the the final section here. But folks, I
want to remind you, do not forget this.
The apostles in Acts, they caused such a
stir not because they were just talking
about Jesus, not because they were
claiming to obey Jesus's commands.
They got into a tizzy because they
claimed Jesus Christ is king.
And you as a government leader, Joe
Biden, Donald Trump, I don't care who it
is, you are subject to the Lord Jesus
and you're going to give an account one
day. So you better repent while you
still have time and you better govern
lawfully in accordance with Christ's
standard because he's king. He's ruling
and reigning. That is what got them into
hot water. And the resurrection was
their the the claim of of of uh
retribution upon them and and a a
mocking fact that this Jesus you killed,
he's alive. He resurrected and he's
ruling and reigning and this is actually
his sphere. This is his domain that
you're a part of. Don't forget that
folks. That is what caused the the
religious leaders of that day to be so
poed.
So when Ellen wants to appeal to the
Jewish leaders etc understand that is
what not this idea that Jesus doesn't
have his hands involved in the current
things he's outside of the world like
looking in. No no no no no that's not
what's going on.
The Lord says this is eternal life that
they may know you the only true God and
Jesus Christ whom you sent. And so you
see friends, the parameter of the gospel
is laid out in scripture. And when you
follow that today, you find that
Protestantism of today is really
apostate when it is no longer following
the dictates of God's word. Now let me
tell you what I mean. Ask yourself the
question, when you watch shows on
television, when you listen to religious
preachers, how often do you hear sin
talked about? Why is that something
that's missing so much in the world
today in the Christian world? You know
why? Because you can't talk about sin
unless you have something to measure sin
by. You can't call a person a sinner, a
liar, an adulterer, a fornicator. You
can't say that a person misrepresents
God, lies, and steals and and bears
bears false witness and covetss or take
God's name in vain or violates the
Sabbath or bows down to images and be
being guilty of that. You can't even
indict a person of any of those things
unless there's a law by which to measure
that person's behavior, to measure that
person's character. And so when those
claiming to be connected with God no
longer preach a message of salvation
against sin or salvation from sin, you
can say, "Wait a minute. Why are they
not talking about salvation from sin?" A
lot of modern preaching is about, "Well,
your ship is coming in." Well, God is
going to make you prosperous. Well, here
are the seven effective principles of
highly effective Christians, but not
about deliverance, not about heaven, not
about turning your life over to Christ,
not about becoming victorious over sin,
not about salvation, not about winning
the struggle against the against the
thing that binds you. Because
Protestantism
is more based now on success and
financial chasing and big houses and big
cars and and getting all the gusto in
life rather than saying to someone
you're struggling with sin, Christ can
give you the victory over sin. That's
why Matthew 1:21 talking about the the
the the the remedial and and essential
foundation of the mission of Christ.
Listen to what the Bible says in Matthew
1 and verse 21. The Bible says, "And she
will bring forth a son,
and you shall call his name Jesus, for
he will save his people from their sin."
Praise the Lord for that. There is
salvation from the penalty of sin.
There's salvation from the power of sin
every day. And there will be salvation
eventually from the presence of sin when
Jesus delivers us from this sinful world
and remedies the sin problem forever.
So Protestants aren't following the
dictates of God's word supposedly.
Yet the things you claim we aren't
following, we've never followed
or agreed with you guys on.
And if you believe first generation
Protestant theology, you're an apostate
according to this guy. And they're the
true Protestants. The 19th century novel
movement that has no connection back to
the church. Like here's the other thing,
folks, you have to realize about when
they try to make these parallels. They
love doing this all the time for like
every area.
He's trying to do it to say they're the
true Protestants. No, no, sir. The
Protestant reformers were Roman
Catholics. They were Catholics. They
weren't just rogue agents saying, you
know, we're just going to up and do
something.
That's not what went down. It's not the
same parallel at all to the SDA
pioneers.
They were seeking to reform the church
universal by the word of God from
already being inside, not starting some
new thing.
And then the rest is history and and
history happened as it did. But the
point being,
don't make this parallel that you guys
are heirs of the Protestant reformers.
No, you're not.
Not even close.
Just own that you're your own thing.
This drives me crazy. And as I started
learning theology after leaving
Adventism, you know, 11 years ago now,
12 years, 11 years ago,
it's just like, wow. It's just like
that's not what's going on at all. Just
own that you're your own thing. Own it.
Rome likes to make this claim about us
that we have no connection really, you
know, back to the church
except the reformers were for the most
part ordained individuals in the Roman
church
that they argued were unlawfully booted.
Nevertheless,
this guy in 2023 is here to tell you,
Lutheran, Anglican, pres Presbyterians,
you're an apostate Protestant because
you don't succumb to the Adventist novel
gospel message, a false prophet,
Judaizing by returning to the old
creation memorial, which pointed to
Jesus, adhering to a vegetarian but
preferably vegan lifestyle, tea
totalling, no presence of Christ in
Eucharist,
no law gospel distinction, rejection of
infant baptism,
just throwing out the sign of the
covenant, that the fact that God is a
no word and sacrament ministry and a
host of other out of step with classical
Protestant teaching that this that this
movement affirms. You're supposed to
give all that up to come join them, the
true Protestants.
No law gospel distinction.
No word and sacrament ministry.
They're the true Protestants.
That was for my Protestant brethren out
there, my classical Protestant brethren
who hear this and think, "What in the
world? What?"
He said, "Turn on the TV and watch
televangelists and see how much you see
sin talked about."
Mr. Lom King,
you are criticizing classical
Protestants in your talk,
making zero distinction between
classical Protestant thought and
modernday evangelicalism.
Televangelists,
sir, that has nothing to do with
classical Protestantism.
This is why you need to study up on what
that means.
It isn't just not Roman Catholic like
you stated at the beginning of the talk.
Modern-day televangelists aren't
Protestant, sir.
Not in the strict the the technical
defense. And you're l it wouldn't matter
if you weren't if you actually made a
distinction,
but you lump us all under the same
umbrella.
Tell these televangelists, they're part
of sex just like you. Word of faith
nonsense like Kenneth Copelan and Joyce
Meyer, prosperity gospel heretics like
Joel Ostein who's basically agnostic.
Yet you throw us in with them and call
us all apostate because we don't believe
like you guys. Sir, I hear about sin
literally every Lord's day, every week.
We have to confess our sins before
approaching the Lord at his table.
Law and gospel are both preached week in
and week out.
The law highlights sin. That's one of
its uses.
I get annoyed with this and frustrated.
Yes, Adventists hear me. Or why are you
getting so worked up, bro? Because this
is a lie. You don't understand what
you're critiquing. You have no clue what
you're criticizing. You're You live in
an alternate universe.
You need to snap out of it. You don't
know what you're critiquing.
Your pioneers didn't make any
distinction. That what I'm espousing was
what was was popular in the day and age
of your pioneers.
Your pioneers came up in a day of my
spiritual ancestors who had the majority
influence in this country.
That's what Ellen White's statements
were made about. Not modern-day
televangelists,
though. They weren't even on the scene.
Those guys are a product of 19th and
20th century charismatic craziness.
This is the problem I have with this
movement.
Adventists will be quick to claim the
critics of their movement are ignorant.
Yet the biggest names in your movement
are some of the most uninformed
individuals
about who it is that they even
criticize.
Give me a break.
In part one, we looked at two Protestant
confessions. Not Joe Schmo evangelical
somewhere in a corner. Bonafiday
Protestant confessions.
What did they say about the law? Did
they say what Mr. Lom King is claiming
about apostate Protestantism
that we have no standard for sin because
we've totally disregarded the law.
We're apparently Antonyomian heretics, a
heresy that was denounced in the 4th
century.
Mr. Lom King, I hope you see this one
day and come to your senses. You seem
like a nice guy. You just kind of give
off that vibe of like you're you're like
a a a seasoned clearly a seasoned public
speaker. You you come across like a nice
guy,
but you're crossing wires.
You're out of your depths.
And I suspect you're just going through
the motions and the script that you've
followed for years.
But virtually all of your criticisms
have zero impact regarding actual
Protestantism.
And if first generation classical
Protestant thought doesn't even fit the
bill for what you're calling Protestant,
then the obvious answer is that you are
in error and you need to recalibrate.
Sin is more than just violating the Ten
Commandments. By the way, the idea that
all of morality is exclusively found in
the decalogue is almost pitiable.
He said, "Protestants no longer preach a
message of freedom from sin."
Avenus, I really hope that you will take
the time to fact check this stuff for
yourself.
This is just embarrassing.
Mr. Lomachang, why are you not able to
point to any sort of source
documentation for any of this?
Why is it TV evangelist anecdotes and
your own an anecdotal going to a couple
churches in your town? You haven't cited
a single primary source for anything
that you've said. Not one.
You've made a ton of assertions.
Yet you state that Protestants don't
teach freedom from sin. Shame on you.
Shame on you.
You don't even know what you're
criticizing. What are you talking about?
Adventism can't even provide you
freedom, folks.
It's not the gospel. They don't have the
gospel. And only the true Christ and his
gospel give freedom. True freedom.
Notice he uses terms like a lot of
modern preaching. No sir. No, no, no,
no, no. You guys claim all of us without
distinction are in the same boat. Not
just modern preaching.
You lump classical Protestants in with
the likes of Joel Ostein and Todd White
and Bill Johnson and other day modern
heretics.
You literally equated modern-day health
and wealth prosperity heresy with
Protestantism.
His definition of Protestant is so
loose. It includes Gnostics,
Kosis heretics, semi-arans, trinity
denying heretics. I mean, come on, dude.
You have to point to that lowhanging
fruit because if you did actually point
to primary source documents, your whole
narrative collapses and people would see
that you have no clue what you're
talking about.
You are quoting people
reject or or you're equating people
sorry
for who reject your guys' false teaching
regarding sinless perfectionism as
rejecting the idea of warning of waring
against sin.
It's like, have you ever read Martin
Luther aside from just citing him to try
and make it look like he agreed with you
guys here and there?
Have you read John Calvin, Martin
Buucer, Peter Martyr, Vermilier,
Basa, Martin Kemnets, or literally any
of the Protestant reformers that you're
claiming Protestants today don't
resemble at all?
Doubt it.
Basing that on what you said in this
presentation, and I've listened to you
elsewhere as well. Matthew 1:21 doesn't
say what you guys claim regarding
sinless perfectionism. Give me a break.
I have yet to meet the Adventist that
has arrived at what you guys claim.
Every SDA I get into with this, it takes
about five seconds before they're
claiming, "Well, I try my best."
Yeah, well, that isn't the standard.
That doesn't mean you don't still try
your best, but it should make you
realize what trying your best actually
pertains to, not keeping you in right
standing with God.
The SDA prophetus claimed one had to
attain to perfect holiness.
Perfect holiness. Adventists,
perfect obedience.
Oh, she meant Christian perfection.
No, not trying your best. We're heirs of
John Wesley. Yeah. Okay.
Notice
the time of trouble which every
generation of SDAs have believed will
happen in their lifetime. What does
Ellen White claim regarding perfection
here? Great controversy. Page 623.
Sorry.
Quote.
Now, while our great high priest is
making the atonement for us,
we should seek to become perfect in
Christ.
Not even by a thought could our savior
be brought to yield to the power of
temptation. So remember, Adventists love
to say, "No, no, no. It's just Christian
perfection. You don't understand. And
that just means trying your best. See,
she's talking about that we should seek
to become perfect in Christ. Okay, let's
see what she means about that.
Not even by a thought could our savior
be brought to yield to the power of
temptation.
Satan finds in human hearts some point
where he can gain a foothold. Some
sinful desire is cherished by means of
which his temptations assert their
power. But Christ declared of himself,
"The prince of this world cometh and
hath nothing in me." John 14:30.
Satan could find nothing in the Son of
God that would enable him to gain the
victory. He had kept his father's
commandments. That's the Ten
Commandments.
And there was no sin in him that Satan
could use to his advantage.
This is the condition in which those
must be found who shall stand in the
time of trouble. Close quote.
So in order to stand in the time of
trouble, you will have to be as perfect
as Jesus was in every thought, word, and
deed.
How perfect is that? Adventist
trying your best.
If you want to make it through the time
of trouble in this system, you'll have
to have arrived at a place where you are
as perfect as Jesus was. No SDA has
arrived at the state. Not a single one.
Same book.
She writes,
quote, "Those who would share the
benefits of the Savior's mediation
should permit nothing to interfere with
their duty to perfect holiness in the
fear of God."
The precious hours instead of being
given to pleasure to display or to gain
seeeking should be devoted to an earnest
prayerful study of the word of truth.
The subject of the sanctuary and the
investigative judgment should be clearly
understood by the people of God.
All need a knowledge for themselves of
the position and work of their great
high priest.
Otherwise, it will be impossible for
them to exercise the faith which is
essential at this time or to occupy the
position which God designs them to fill.
Every individual has a soul to save or
to lose. Each has a case pending at the
bar of God. Each must meet the great
judge face to face. Close quote.
So, if you want Jesus to be mediating
for you, you must permit nothing to
interfere with what?
perfect holiness,
not trying your best. Perfect.
Otherwise, it will be impossible for you
to exercise the faith necessary to be
saved and to occupy the position that
God has intended for you to fill.
Yes, it is perfection because if you
study the system, any sin on your books,
unconfessed or forgotten,
because if it's forgotten, it still
remains on the books, that will give
Satan an ability to cast shame on that
individual, and Christ won't be able to
demonstrate that he's just and fair in
saving that individual in the the
courtroom scene.
No, it's not. Trying your best and then,
oh, God just winks over the rest of
them.
Trying your best is what Christians
believe. Genuinely seeking Christ and
believing,
relying on him daily for strength.
That's not what Adventism teaches.
And I know some SDAs love to downplay
this, but no. your movement teaches uh
what your movement teaches as standard
fail standard fair run-of-the-mill by
the book good oldfashioned SDA teaching
is sinless perfectionism last generation
theology moral man theology
and it's codified in your system
of theology by way of Ellen White
Again, it's why last generation theology
and why that crowd exists.
As if it could be said or couldn't be
said any more plainly.
Quote,
"Those only who through faith in Christ
obey all of God's commandments will
reach the condition of sinlessness in
which Adam lived before his
transgression."
Close quote.
trying your best. No.
And if you aren't sinlessly perfect, you
must not have enough faith to empower
you to obey perfectly in thought, word,
and deed, and motive. Cuz that's the
condition Adam was in.
Mr. Lomachang, you are kidding yourself
if you think that you are sinless.
You've demonstrated this isn't the case
multiple times in this presentation.
the idea that if we disagree with this
convoluted idea
that that of of essentially of the
Christian war with sin that therefore
means we don't believe Matthew 1:21
no false dilemma fallacy again sinless
perfectionism is just more ancient
heresy that the SDA church resurrected
amongst all the other ancient heresies
they affirm but claim were special
truths that were lost and recovered by
them. No, they weren't lost. They were
just damnable heresies that were put to
bed that you guys resurrected. But
today, the dismissive gospel includes
phrases like, "Well, we are all sinners
anyway." I was talking to somebody just
recently. They said, "Well, you know,
we're all sinners. We pray and we
stumble over our lives." And I said,
"Wait a minute. Wait a minute. You mean
you pray and you keep stumbling?" Well,
they said, "Well, that's the way it is."
I said, "Friends, no. There is salvation
in Christ. There's victory in Christ.
There's deliverance in Christ. If your
Christianity has done nothing for you,
don't prescribe or recommend what
doesn't work to you to somebody else.
And the only way they want to be what
you are is if it works for you. If it
doesn't work for you, if you find no
deliverance, don't try to sell me what
doesn't work for you. The evidence of a
powerful life is that Christ Jesus is
seen and there is deliverance from the
power of sin. That's why the apostle
Paul says in Romans 5 and verse 19,
listen to what he says. For as by one
man's disobedience,
many were made sinners, so also by one
man's obedience, that is Jesus Christ,
many will be made righteous. Hallelujah
to that. Adam messed up, but Jesus
didn't. Adam led me down a faulty road
and gave me a body that was always
against the principles and the character
of Christ, but Jesus didn't. Through
Jesus's obedience, we can be made
righteous and we can be by his strength
live in obedience to his commandments.
Another anecdotal experience.
Yes, John, we are all sinners. What do
you mean by this?
That's the question.
You guys just assume
that because a person points this out,
it means they think, "So therefore,
I can just live however I want or
something like that."
Yet, no. Christians have been for nearly
2,000 2,000 years
have properly understood the sinful
nature of man.
You see it developing early early early
early on. This is an area that was
systematized in Augustine's day.
But furthermore, even long before that,
considering Paul the Apostle was a
Christian and he penned Romans 6 and 7,
you keep pointing to modern evangelical
nonsense like Walter V does and then use
that to broadbrush Protestantism simply
because those individuals aren't Roman
Catholic. So because they're not Roman
Catholic, we can use them to to to to
swindle the rest or or swaddle and wrap
the rest of Protestantism in.
Well, neither's Eastern Orthodoxy or
Oriental Orthodoxy or the Coptic Church
or the Assyrian Church of the East. So
they're all Protestants now. He said
people won't ever struggle with certain
sins for potentially long periods of
time because there's victory in Christ.
That's essentially what he was saying.
John, you don't have total freedom from
sin. You aren't sinlessly perfect.
You've demonstrated such in this video.
You bore false witness against
Christians. And they love to say, "Oh,
sin is only recognized when it's uh in
the no." No, it isn't. There's called
sins of omission and commission.
It just again, it's this very truncated
like real remedial understanding of
like, oh, the ten commandments are just
these 10 things and it's this real
surface level understanding. It's like,
man, meditate on Matthew 5.
The Lord Jesus expounding upon the law
even shows the spirit behind the law is
goes far beyond the letter of the law.
There's something deeper going on. You
have a a much bigger problem than that.
You have a a a human condition problem.
He he said, "Adam gave me this body of
death." Yes, you were you were so close,
sir. Yet you guys don't believe that you
actually inherited a nature.
You believe that God by faith will give
you an upgrade to your current hardware,
allowing you to do something you
couldn't previously do in your current
fallen body.
You don't love the true God with every
thought, word, deed, and motive 24/7,
365. That's the standard. You don't do
that because just like the rest of us,
you live in a fallen flesh and it flares
up. This idea that you have mastered
your flesh. You're just you're kidding
yourself, dude. You're kidding yourself.
And then when you point this out, they
say, "Oh, so you're just advocating for
sin." It's just a constant false
dichotomy. It's like, "No, I live in
reality. I realize that
life has seasons.
changes, things you experience that you
didn't expect, and things that flare up
that are out of harmony with how God
designed things to be. That stuff is
sin.
That yes, at the resurrection, there's
going to be glorification where, like
Romans 3 tells us, for all have sinned
and fall short of the glory of God.
That's not going to be the case anymore
because there's going to be a change in
the being. Until then, we war with sin.
But I want to play a clip here, folks. I
know it's getting late.
But I want to play a clip from Justin
Peters who was responding to to fake
faith healer. I mention mentioned him
earlier, Todd White. Since Mr. Lomang
wants to use the lowhanging fruit and
saddle all of us with it, this is who he
sounds like when he claims this. Get
this.
So, I've honestly I've been say for 18
years. I've not lied for 18 years.
Yeah. He came and gave me this blank
canvas. He came and gave me this pure
heart and I've never violated it with
anything because I love Jesus. My hands
are clean. My heart is pure. I love him
with all my heart. I'm going to stand
before him and he's going to say, "Well
done." What's he going to say when you
stand before him?
You could actually have the word so
strong inside of your heart that you
never have to slip.
People are like, "Well, that's false.
That's not true." Well, you're wrong. I
live with me.
And so, for 13 years, I've been free
from that. I've never looked lustly with
lust at a woman ever.
I live with me. My kids will tell you
that I'm a man of God. I'm a father.
Because God doesn't say he wants you 97%
pure.
I mean, was Jesus 97% pure? If you wake
up in love with Jesus, if you go to
sleep in love with Jesus, if you wake up
in the middle of the night in love with
Jesus, you will fulfill the first
command. The first commandment is to
love God with all your heart, with all
your soul, with all your strength, with
all your mind. I'm not holier than thou.
I just love Jesus 24/7.
Todd White says that he has not sinned,
not a single time since the day he got
saved. And granted, those clips are a
few years old. And you may be thinking,
well, surely he's grown in his
understanding of the gospel since then
and uh human nature. No, apparently he
has not because this clip that my video
began with when he said, "I have not
lied in 18 years." uh that was posted
December the 1st, 2023.
The same type of charlatans you want to
saddle us with are who you guys sound
like when you go on about your your
perfect lawkeeping and sinlessness.
Folks, avoid this guy like the plague.
No better than Adventism.
Todd White is so holy. He's one of
these. He glows in the dark, you know?
He he he's so holy that he's not holier
than thou. He just loves Jesus perfectly
24/7 365 and is just like Jesus. Not 97%
100%.
Mr. Lomang, he teaches what you guys do
regarding sinless perfectionism.
Just like you guys, he teaches Jesus
being the great example moral uh uh the
model man theology
except he's bold enough to claim he
hasn't sinned since professing faith in
Jesus 18 years.
Only a person folks with a totally
warped perspective of the actual
standard and holiness of God would make
such a statement. And it's always these
Pelagian types that fall into this mess
because they have a totally botched view
and understanding of man's nature and
condition and how holy God is.
Christians recognize the act of war with
sin Romans 7 style which includes both
sins of commission and omission.
Mr. Lom King, if you guys actually
understood the Lord's supper,
you guys would realize
why it's important to partake of it more
than every 13th week or whatever you
guys do. The supper is a means of grace.
Again, this goes back to the word and
sacrament ministry. This is like
Protestantism 101.
You receive Christ and his benefits in
the Eucharist.
It is used by God to grow a believer in
their faith and their war with sin and
their desire to follow Christ.
Again, you can't be doing this if you're
just cut off from the body, completely
rogue.
This is Protestant thought 101.
You'd realize this if you actually
understood what you're criticizing
and didn't beat up a a totally different
concept and idea such as the health,
wealth, and prosperity heretics like
Todd White.
Those are the people that you're
saddling us with. You said modern day
preaching is all dude Protestants
completely denounce.
This is why so many SDAs are secretly
suffocating and anxious.
They put on the fake Adventist veneer
in front of other SDAs. Oh, you know, to
give the illusion of perfect happiness
and total freedom from sin, yet inside
they're in like total turmoil. They have
no peace. They have no hope. They feel
inadequate because they know that they
still fall short. I don't care what they
say in the comments. I've talked with
countless SDAs who in private this is
what they're saying because that's what
Adventism produces. It's a fake veneer.
We've we have total victory. Adventism
gives you total victory. That's total
nonsense, dude. I've had far more
freedom from sin being a Protestant ever
than Adventism was able to provide
because Adventism is a total facade of
the actual Christian experience.
Other former Adventists, you can attest
to this.
Because if you disagree with people like
John Lomachang, they'll claim you just
love your sin. You want to wallow in it,
not be free. When no, the reality is the
sinful flesh hasn't been glorified yet.
Completely eliminating the sin nature
for good. Paul explains this Romans 7 uh
1 Corinthians 15.
and John, it has worked for me.
Because what's promised isn't sinless
perfectionism, but a daily struggle of
picking up your cross and bearing it.
Doesn't mean every person is going to be
like an Apostle Paul. The vast vast vast
vast majority of Christians in history
are everyday husbands, wives, men, women
who the world knows nothing of.
No one saw them. They weren't under a
spotlight. They loved their their wife
the way that Christ loves the the
church. They loved their husband the way
that Christ has commanded them to,
despite his behavior. They served their
family, their children, whatever it may
be, their local church, and no one even
saw it.
But despite all that, they were waring
with their sin.
What's promised is not a daily struggle
or or or sorry, what's promised is not a
a a sinless perfectionism,
but a daily struggle in picking up your
cross and bearing it until you're
resurrected and glorified or the Lord
Jesus returns before them
and then you're glorified like that.
Sometimes you fall under that cross
before then continuing to press onward
because it runs a lot deeper than just
oh the mere letter of the Ten
Commandments.
Hypocrisy, pride, slothfulness,
not loving your wife perfectly, being
impatient with a family member
because life happens and natural
emotions happen due to your fallen
condition.
because we don't live in a Adventist
fairy tale where you don't recognize
that es and flows of life happen
and that sin is not simply just
violating the letter of the ten
commandments
and your guys' standard of only when
it's knowingly engaging in is a man-made
standard. Scripture doesn't know
anything of that. There was entire
It's like during the Mosaic period,
there's entire provisions for sins of
ignorance.
Again, we heard the claim that people
will only be attracted to Christ if they
hear what worked for you. No, the gospel
is not pragmatism, my friend.
You have a wrong view of the nature of
fallen man and and and his disposition
that he has toward God, like we looked
at earlier. But then he cited Romans 5.
We're gonna end on on this, folks. I
know it's getting late, but then he
cited Romans 5:19.
Nope.
That is not about sinless perfectionism.
Mr. Lomachang, this paricopy is talking
about headship,
not sinless perfectionism.
You conveniently left out the full
context of a statement. That's a
summation statement after other things
previously said. Notice Romans 5
12-19.
Therefore,
so Paul just got done talking about why
is the therefore there? Paul just got
done talking about how a person is
reconciled to God by the person and work
of Jesus is what he explains. He says it
three different ways in the past and
present tense.
So therefore, just as sin entered the
world through one man, Adam, and death
through sin.
And in this way, death came to all
people because all sinned,
not just Adam. All sinned.
To be sure, sin was in the world before
the law was given. ah before Moses sin
was in the world but sin is not charged
against anyone's account where there is
no law nevertheless so why is that the
case if death reigned from the time of
Adam to the time of Moses
even those who did not sin by breaking a
command
as did Adam
who is a pattern of the one to come the
second Adam.
But the gift is not like the trespass.
For if the many, that's the all that was
in reference earlier in Adam.
If the many died by the transgress or
the trespass of the one man, how much
more did God's grace and the gift that
came by the grace of the one man, Jesus
Christ, overflow to the many.
Nor can the gift of God, the gift of
God, be compared with the result of one
man's sin. The judgment followed one sin
and brought condemnation, but the gift
followed many trespasses and brought
justification.
For if by the trespass of the one man,
Adam, death reigned through that one
man, how much more will those who
receive God's abundant provision of
grace and of the gift of righteousness
reign in life through the one man, Jesus
Christ.
Consequently, just as one trespass,
Adam, resulted in condemnation for all
people,
so also one righteous act, Jesus,
resulted in justification and life for
all people, those that are in him.
For just as through the disobedience of
the one man, Adam, the many were made
sinners,
so also through the obedience of the one
man, the many will be made righteous.
Thus, the reading of God's holy word.
This is talking about headship. the
first Adam and the second Adam. You're
either in the fallen
kingdom of darkness, Adam who fell or
you're in the second Adam who came and
redeemed and restored what that first
Adam destroyed and broke by sinning.
You guys don't teach Mr. Lomachang that
by one man all sinned.
Meaning Adam was the representative head
of all of humanity in Eden. And when he
fell, we fell in him. Which is why all
people are born dead in their trespasses
and sins, a slave to sin. And they're
already in the kingdom of darkness by
default.
One is born united to the first Adam,
not Christ. They're not born a child of
God and then they sin and then now
they're a a son of or daughter of Adam
and then they get brought back to Christ
if they they to him. No,
that is a plane. Thus sayeth the Lord.
By the way,
you guys are Pelagians in your
anthropology.
You guys don't teach that by Christ's
perfect active and passive obedience,
the many are seen as righteous.
You guys don't teach that salvation is a
gift like Paul repeatedly calls it. You
believe by way of Ellen White, it is a
reward.
And we've looked at this many times
regarding Ellen White's statements.
You guys teach that Christ obtained the
possibility to impart righteousness to
people who through their own obedience
can have Christ's righteousness given to
them in small spurts over time leading
to eventual sinless perfection and a
righteousness of your own that mirrors
Christ that was developed and built up
over time.
Thus, you have the righteousness of
Christ, a righteousness as perfect as
Jesus is.
That's what they mean, Christian, when
they try to say, "No, no, righteousness
by faith." 1888. It just
This is not even close to what Paul is
laying out in Romans 5. This is after
he's already explained how Abraham was
justified and how a person has peace
with God, is reconciled to God, etc.
It's by the perfect work of Jesus. Not
that plus man's obedience.
Doesn't mean there won't be obedience,
but obedience is in a different
category.
And this is another area that evidences.
No, you guys are not Protestant. You
don't understand justification like
Protestants. And you sound medieval in
your in your sotiology.
Your sior sotiology sounds a lot like
the dark ages.
Paul is explaining something seen
throughout all of scripture in Romans 5,
which is headship. The male represents
the descendants.
We see this with Adam, the second Adam,
Jesus. The genealogies in scripture.
When a person is transferred from having
Adam as their representative to having
Christ, the second Adam, as their new
representative,
they are seen as righteous by virtue of
their union with Christ.
Not because they add something to what
Christ has done through their obedience.
Having a desire to obey Christ flows out
of being united to him.
That union is solely a work of God. This
is like Protestantism 101.
the irony of of this talk being titled
Protestantism or a you know apostate
Protestantism. It's like dude this is
Protestant thinking 101 headship union
with Christ. It just
folks understand that this movement does
not understand what they criticize.
Adventist apologists will claim that no
one actually understands what they
believe, especially former Adventists.
They're always misrepresented, etc. This
is all projection.
It's them. They have no clue what they
criticize. It's them that don't know
history.
John, not a single charge that you
brought up in this talk actually applies
to actual Protestants.
Not a single one.
As we saw in part one, your entire talk
was built upon a sinking sand
foundation. You incorrectly defined
Protestant as merely protesting the
Catholic Church, which says nothing
about what Protestants believe.
You told us that unless something is a
plain thus sayeth the Lord, that it
should be rejected. Yet time and time
again, you would paraphrase Ellen White,
sprinkle in a couple a couple verses of
scripture and then claim what you said
was a plain thus sayith the Lord. When
no, not a single verse that you cited in
this talk actually said what you claimed
is a plain, thus sayith the Lord. Not a
single one.
It's like the the the most the craziest
one is Revelation 16:16.
what you said is a plain thus sayith the
Lord in that verse.
It's like are any of the same words even
used in that verse that you're claiming
was the plain thus sayith the Lord.
You engaged in word association fallacy
over and over and over again. You
engaged in hasty generalization fallacy.
You engaged in straw man fallacy. You
engaged in ad homonym fallacy and on and
on and on.
If you're going to get on the airwaves
like I'm doing and claim
make claims about a group in this case
Protestants or Apostate, you should
probably site at least one primary
source document. Don't you think? I
mean, is that an unreasonable standard?
You didn't. You cited various anecdotal
experiences that you had and then
broadbrushed these as being
representative of Protestantism proper
or pointed to health, wealth, and
prosperity heretics.
When the Protestant reformers don't even
fit your qualifications and definitions
of Protestant,
if that's the case, you're probably the
one that's confused, not Protestants.
What we saw here is another classic
example of how the great controversy
theme filters all of SDA thought and
theology.
They will paraphrase Ellen White,
not mention her by name. Oftent times
SDAs don't even know the talking points
and and and arguments they've been
given. That's what they're paring.
So they'll paraphrase Ellen White.
There's no mention of her name. Take her
commentary to the Bible. read some
verses and then boldly assert that their
interpretation is a thus sayeth the Lord
when 90% of the time it doesn't even say
what they claim.
So folks understand Adventism is not
Protestant.
You are your own thing. You need to own
that. Stop trying to ride the coattails
of others to add legitimacy to the SDA
movement. You claim to be your own
thing, restoring the truth. You have all
this extra light. etc. Own it.
Okay.
The reformers were Roman Catholics.
What do you think the term reformed for
the reformed tradition, the
Presbyterians,
the Canton regions, etc. What do you
think that term means? Reformed what?
Reformed baboons. a a reformed
Catholics.
They were booted from the Roman church
unlawfully.
Different discussion for a different
day. The point being Protestants go back
to the Catholic Church, the universal
church, the universal Christian faith.
Christianity was not born in the 16th
century. It wasn't born in the 19th
century.
Yet in Adventism, that really is the
thinking. I'm not saying every SDA
thinks that way, but I can tell you from
I don't know how many I've engaged with
being taught in SDA University, etc.
It's like every touch point, I know
that's anecdote as well, but my
goodness, it's like every single touch
point you read, you engage with, you get
educated with, etc., there's an
undergirling idea that Christianity was
resurrected in the 19th century.
No.
And there's the idea that the Protestant
reformers rose up as like these
revolutionaries just like William Miller
or the Ellen White or whoever. No.
And this idea that they were
revolutionaries that rose up as
vigilantes on a mission to start a new
church.
No. That's what the SDA pioneers were.
They had no affiliation to the universal
church. They were hopping around from
one heretical sect to another.
and then eventually culminating in
claiming they were now the true church
and if you don't join them you'll be
lost. That hasn't changed to this day.
They've simply repackaged and rewarded
things to try and heed Ellen White's
advice that we saw in the early
adventist missionary in uh what she said
to the early adventist missionary in
England.
Protestants are worse than heathen.
We're not to call them. We're not to
tell them that though, lest the way to
proitize them close up before us. The
target in the sights of this
organization is Christians. Period.
We're their number one enemy that, as
you heard, Satan
is in control of and is ultimately using
not just to attack the character of God,
but the Seventh Day Adventist Church.
It's Protestants that are leading this
new charge in reinstituting national
papal rule. It's Protestants that will
incite world outrage leading to a
supposed death decree to go down to to
to go and hunt down 7th Adventist.
So Christian, please recognize when
people in this movement try and buddy
buddy up with you, when they try and
claim, "No, no, no, brother, we're just
like you." They are either ignorant or
they've been taken captive or they are
lying.
Because no, we are not brothers and
sisters in Christ with them. I want that
to be the case. I'm not saying I don't
want that. It's just the facts. I'm
sorry, Adventists. We are not on the
same team.
We use a lot of the same language. We do
not mean the same things.
And I will keep saying that and keep
watching God use it to wake people up
and bring them to a knowledge of the
truth. This is not a game. It's not just
poking fun on the internet.
You're not our brothers and sisters in
Christ.
You need to come to a knowledge of the
truth.
The SDA church has a totally unique
mission only given to them. It's not the
same mission as the Christian church. We
saw Ted Wilson say this at the 2023
annual council.
The SDA church has their own mission,
folks. It's different than the Christian
churches.
They think they're the remnant, the true
people of God in the last days. them and
only them.
No, not even other seventh day
sabotarian groups. You have to have
Ellen White who's the identifying mark
of the remnant supposedly as well as the
three angels messages. The modern flavor
of liberal Adventism that wants to
postulate,
oh, Adventism is a big tenth to try and
distill it down to merely the belief in,
oh, the imminent return of Christ and
Seventh Day Sabbath, as the name says,
Seventh Day uh Adventist.
No, you're just trying to repackage and
and do a faceelift and boil it down to
this sort of mere Adventism.
No.
While I clearly disagree with John
Lomachang, I respect the fact that he's
a by the book Adventist. He isn't afraid
to shy away from what the Adventist
system of theology teaches. He's not a
cherrypicker. He doesn't do the beat
around the bush game.
They think Protestants are deceived
apostates and need the Adventist message
to wake them up and save them from
Babylon. Do not fall for it.
The sad irony is that Adventists need
the true Christ and the true gospel
both.
If they affirm official SDA doctrine and
teaching, they are lost. They will end
up in hell. They will be damned.
That's just the sad fact of the matter.
That's why we're doing this. All
emotionalism aside, that's irrelevant to
the facts.
They will end up in hell, folks.
Which is why we need to be praying for
them, sharing the truth with them when
you encounter them online, in person,
wherever,
millions of people.
The gospel is the good news of the
person and work of Jesus and that you
can be reconciled to God by faith in his
person and work. His vicarious death on
the cross for all of your sins.
That's the good news that the Messiah
has come. He redeemed the creation. He
purchased it with his own blood.
He's presently making all things new,
which includes sinners, of which all of
us are. The cure to your sin problem
isn't believing the investigative
judgment, the health message, Ellen
White, conditional immortality, or any
of the SDA pillar doctrines.
Because believing all of that will not
give you peace with God.
It won't make you righteous in his
sight.
You can believe all of the SDA church's
novel theology and still fail to enter
God's rest eternity
because what the SDA church is selling
isn't the gospel.
They take the gospel and then pile on a
bunch of other stuff on top of it and
make it so convoluted and confusing
to uphold a narrative regarding 1844.
You need to recognize your sinful
disposition and how holy God is,
which is what will bring you to a point
of crushing weight under your sin.
Recognizing that you've sinned against
Almighty God,
you deserve eternal damnation.
When that clicks, and only then
do you realize the mercy of God and
cling to Christ and him alone. Not
Christ plus your obedience. Christ
alone.
Obedience comes after a person's been
united to Christ by faith, been washed
of all their sins, made a new creature
in Christ, etc.
Believe the gospel, friends. Believe the
gospel. Trust in Christ and his
vicarious death on the cross for your
sins. Until next time, God bless.
[Music]